Film Courage: Toward the end of your book what
you don't learn in film school Shane you have this
story it's a fascinating story where you said you
saved a Hollywood studio what 50 million it was?
Shane: About yeah and it was it was for a very
large trilogy that they were producing at the time
and what had happened is they they had committed
to making three blockbuster movies tent polls
over the course of I think five or six years
and they had tremendous success with the
first one it was it was everything that they
make these kind of movies for and more and
the second one had come out and not done very well
and I got a phone call one day from somebody that
I had worked with when I was doing studio work
and I guess he had talked to one of the heads
of production at this other studio and said you
need to kind of flip the script on your mindset
you really need to get an indie rat to look at
your budget your schedule and your script and
let somebody go in with the mindset that
understands production at this level
but thinks thinks how do you make something for
a dollar really for a dime and I got a phone call
out of the blue one day and it was the head of
production for a studio and they they had me come
in they wouldn't talk much about it on the phone
it was very hush-hush and covert everything was
in code and I walked into the boardroom and
there was all these people sitting around a
horseshoe table with their fiji bottles of water
and their highlighter pens or sharpies and their
pads of paper and they had a seat for me and
I couldn't figure out why I was there and
one of the the head-head people came in
he was wearing a suit I remember that
and told me the situation and what they
were dealing with and how they had made
really big commitments going into the third that
the second film's lack of success did not justify
they but they were contractually obligated
to certain escalations in people's pay
they were shooting in different countries
all over the world so they asked if I would
take a look at the they wanted me to look
at the first two films then they wanted me
to break down the third one just from my
perspective and it was it was heavy cgi it
was a big tentpole studio movie it's not what
I do but they had me go through everything and
we spent a few days I had to do everything there
I wasn't allowed to leave with any materials
my cell phone had to be far there was a
person in the room with me at all times
and just broke it down and it's just common sense
common sense common sense and then i'd see a way
to save a lot of money and they would tell me no
you can't do that because we have this contract in
place or there are these agreements with unions
or we have to pay these actors these scales but
it was interesting looking at a budget for
a film that was over 200 million dollars
I mean when you're making films that are
comfortably in that million dollar range
and you you find a place for every dime and you
make sure it stretches and you start looking at
where money is going at dollars at that level it's
mind-blowing the money that's spent wasted that'll
never see the screen perk packages daily per
diems and bonuses and private jets back and forth
hotels that cost a fortune that these these
actors will be in to just sleep a couple
hours a few hours a night it's mind-blowing
and so I felt very fortunate to be a part of
that process it it reminded me of the difference
between being an independent filmmaker and
and really being in embedded with the studio
system and this was at a time when when the
studios were just spending so much money and
there I don't think there was a real checks and
balances on where these these dollars were going
it was it's about give the actors what they need
give the filmmakers what they need above
the line producers I think there were
17 of them 18 of them that's not including the
talent cinematographers and high-end crew I mean
there were some really big crew people on this too
and this was a big film and I think looking back
that I don't think anything's changed with them
it's no surprise that a studio will gladly spend
200 million dollars to make 20 million I mean
that's obviously not the goal but that's kind
of the business model for a lot of the studios
a lot of people say well 80 of studio films fail
that's true but what we deem a failure just
because we look at the domestic box office doesn't
mean globally it was a failure it's a lot of ways
that they can still make money on ancillaries and
different outlets for their project or plushies
and toys and all the stuff that come with it but
it was an interesting experience and it it really
made me appreciate what we do as independent
filmmakers and and why I really I think it was an
experience like that because I just come off of
making gridiron gang shortly before and was lining
up to do some more studio and network projects
and I remember walking away from that and just
saying sure who wouldn't want a paycheck like
some of these people were getting of course we
who wouldn't but when it comes down to getting
movies made and loving what you do and who you
do it with and passion for maybe it's your art
passion for working with the people you care about
or just want to kick a movie out every year or two
it really it really kind of helped push me
into the direction of just saying what that
that isn't what I want to pursue I want to be
able to find people that want to go get their
hands dirty stretch a buck shoot where we're
not supposed to shoot shoot with cameras that
aren't the newest or the coolest and go make
fun movies that people may or may not like
it was kind of a life-changing experience for me
I'm glad we saved the studio a lot of money I mean
it was I couldn't remember it was 38 or 52. I
haven't read that part of the book in a while
but there was we saved them a lot of money I mean
and just common sense money where was most of the
money being spent that you ended up cutting most
of the money was believe it or not studios spend
an outrageous amount of money in post-production
on films like that and they have contracts they
have ways that they're going to put money
into something from one account into another
that that happens when they'll have three edit
bays working on one film that's a walk and talk
drama they can have an apprentice editor setting
things up for the assistant editor the assistant
editor setting up things for the other editor and
the amount of money they're charging for these
these kit fees and these bungalow rentals and
there are there are union jobs so those pay scales
are what they are unless you're getting
an academy award winner a real hot editor
but what I notice is just I know a lot of veterans
I mean editing's my back my background cgi I've
got a lot of people in my life that do that
and when you start budgeting things and you
start getting teams of 30 40 50 people to do
something that you see you can cut this down
you don't have to go this route you could
go to a different country you don't have a
contract with this country to do post you can talk
to these guys here they would love your business
and probably cut this most of these things
were done in post and cgi and and just kind
of reworking perks I mean it was even studios
have their private jets they they perk out
and have deals with hotels all over the world but
there's only so many jets to go around so it was
it even got to the point where we were literally
making deals with other private charter services
and other people that we knew in the private
airline business that were able to help save
a lot of money because a flight from la to new
york people don't realize a private plane flight
could cost over 20 grand it's not a cheap flight
so imagine flying people from la to other parts
of the world and trying to just connect dots with
transportation coordinators that weren't going to
bruise any egos but just kind of inform some
of the executives on where they could go
and that's what we did now how much money they
ended up using on that savings or how much
whatever the dollar amount was that we saved I
don't know what they ended up spending I just
know on paper following all their guidelines and
rules and their what they asked us to adhere to in
putting together a new budget it was it was pretty
substantial for all I know they spent more than
that than the original budget they probably
did but it checked everything checked out
it was doable and during this meeting were there
certain topics that made them uncomfortable when
you said let's cut this and we'll do this and
we'll move this over here and you could see ooh
that's that's probably not going to work
for them there's a lot of looking around
what I found in in in a system like that is it
there's a pecking order there is a hierarchy
and and as there isn't most business and a lot of
people when you'd suggest something you wouldn't
get one person saying yes or no you get a lot of
people looking to one or two different people and
then looking to another person and then it just
ends up going to the head of the table anyway so
it's it's rare people are going to go out on a
limb and say that's that's what we need to do
it kind of the ideas always played pinball
or would come back after three or four
discussions to a no or hey that's good can we
try this over there and they were very forward
thinking once they started seeing it wasn't like I
reinvented the wheel for them it was just getting
them to just kind of throttle back a little bit
on the hemorrhaging of money on everything giving
everybody everything okay you have made these
commitments to these actors I get that but they
don't need to know what you're spending on these
things these gift perks these hotel rooms or
these other perks that go on
that these actors are giving up
films at that level there's different ways to
to still give them what you're contractually
obligated to give them and save and we were
getting to the point we were literally saving
two three hundred dollars on every gift basket
I mean that's that's the kind of stuff we were
literally getting down to we were doing everything
we could to save them money gift basket so that is
a typical thing on certain sets oh sure sure the
studios treat their actors really well and I think
even independent filmmakers should if they don't
when you get an actor that shows up on your film
that's a special get I think I think welcoming
them with something even if it's a fruit basket
or a bottle of nail polish or something is good
but studios they they have some really and there's
a lot of sponsorship that comes with that too
it's kind of like the oscars but there is costs
there are all sorts of things that go into these
things that cost money everything costs money
and when you start going in with the mindset of
okay instead of just saying you're gonna spend
five thousand dollars on every gift basket
and it's gonna end up costing you 2500 to 3500
after you get the free how do you make them feel
equally special for five or six hundred dollars
and it's it's doable it's just about taking the
time to break it down and not just throwing the
money at the problem sure and then you said
the hotel room where they may just stay over
well yeah unfortunately there wasn't a lot we
could do with hotel rooms because of contracts
various studios and production entities especially
when studios are going to other parts of the world
there are a lot of setups already so they're
not going to you're not going to go in and
ruffle too many feathers with that but it's
just the cost and it's reminding them that
you may not think 5 000 for a gift basket is a
lot of money for an actor but you're also spending
this much at night on a hotel room and in reality
they're going to spend 12 12 hours a day on a set
then they're going to be doing this this this
press junket maybe this and at the end of the day
this is with the exception of their days off this
is where they're going to hang their head at night
and how how can some of these things be
worked out and I think most of those things
were kind of finagled more for not the
top tier level of actor but it was about
finding other similar accommodations that were
substantially lower I mean it's it's not rocket
surgery I mean I've got I've got a nephews
getting married at pebble beach coming up
and they threw us all the available hotels and I
mean I think the rooms start at 1200 1400 a night
and those two things I don't pay for myself
is a nice fancy hotel room and a first-class
airfare I'm just sitting on a plane going from a
to b i'll do a coach I have no problem with that
I made three phone calls and I I'm basically five
minutes from the wedding spending 209 a night for
the wedding that's just the mentality that I
have I just think there's money that is better
served somewhere else and and so I that's the
mentality I kind of took with them and everything
and they were receptable to a lot
of the ideas again did they end up
doing it I know I wasn't leaving until I was able
to show them a savings so they at least accepted
what I presented at the end of the day but I
couldn't tell you what they ended up spending
you never know but I know that they were they
were concerned going in and needed needed some
cuts so I don't think they just brought me
in to have me warm a seat for three days
well I don't want to blow my street cred here
but what is an indie rat I'm an indie rat it's
people that just they don't wait for the machine
they figure out a way it's I always I talk about
in the book is give me an actor a camera and a
place to do it and let's go make a movie it's it's
not waiting for a machine to decide when all the
stars align I had when we did gridiron gang we
made that deal I believe in 1993 it was the most
sought after property in Hollywood everybody had
bid on it but paramount and hundreds of producers
directors and actors all wanted to be a part of it
and then it gets to the studio and it took two
years to finally go into turnaround it never
got made and fast forward to 2006 and I just
I know not every film goes through that but
it's not uncommon and I had spent some time at
a network after doing gridiron I was brought on
to to develop in-house projects for a major
network with a writing partner of mine at the
time and we spent I think 13 months there talking
about a lot of great projects that never got made
and these were passion projects that the network
wanted to do these weren't our ideas it was we
were brought in to do the passion projects
that the high ups wanted to see get made
and the meetings and the development discussions
and i'll never forget it the the vp of the
the network brought me into his office one day
after our 100th development meeting on one show
and it was friday and he said you like scotch I
said I like scotch he poured us a scotch we put
our feet up on his coffee table and shot
the breeze for a few minutes and he said
you're a filmmaker man you don't belong here
he said I can see your frustration he said
I he's you'll always have an open door with
me but I think you need to just go out and
make movies he goes this isn't how you work I said
yeah I just don't understand it I said we've been
here 13 months we've gone from this project for
four months to oh that's not cool anymore let's
jump on this one oh that's that's not gonna fit
in today's climate and then we go to something
else and I said here we're on round three in
13 months and we haven't done anything I said
my idea is write something that you're excited
about get some friends together and go shoot it
and that's that's what I do that's what I believe
in and I think at that point I had just gotten to
in my life was where it was about just just doing
what we wanted to do and it doesn't agree with
everybody and not everybody likes what I do and
that's not why I don't do it for people like it
I do it because I need to do it to just to feel
alive that's what I need to do and it's it's been
it's been a lot of fun and and I wouldn't trade
those days in doing the studio film or working
with the networks the way I did it it taught
me so much to be able to do what I do today
because I can see it from both sides I can see it
from a creative person who doesn't have a lot of
budget to work with but I also know the end game
and when this thing is done where it has to go
how it how it has to be exploited around the world
and and making sure we check the boxes that all 54
territories and 172 countries that are out there
that buy there's something in it for everybody
how can the quote unquote indie rats and the
quote unquote suits harmoniously work together
because each needs each other each needs
each other that's a that is a great
question I wish I had all the answers and I i'd
like to think I play well with others I some of
the greatest relationships I've had in this town
have been with the suits and I p what people we
all have to remember this is a business at the end
of the day but it's like let's take something like
the car business which we talked about before you
have the people that actually design the cars that
have jobs designing and engineering then you have
the people that actually have to be the executives
behind the decision to greenlight a car being made
and then you have the car dealerships that are
going to acquire the cars and then you have the
salesmen who have to sell them and then you got
the mechanics who have to work on them everybody
needs each other it's kind of like on a film set
we have a rule where I don't care if you're the
star of the show if you're a pa you're all equal
to this machine running in in harmony and we all
need to show respect for one another and I think
I think there's always been a little bit of a
clash between the suits and the the filmmaker
but I think if if people can get on the same
page and I think I think if the executives would
trust the artist that they're giving their
money to or distributing I think if you fall
in love with an idea you fall in love with the
script or a filmmaker's vision from a previous
film you need to decide I either trust this person
to run with it or I don't and I think when you get
too many cooks in the kitchen I think it stifles
the creativity I know I've been involved with some
pretty pretty big projects where the suits and
the artists couldn't ever get along it got very
very intense it got it got
explosive at times even on sets
where a studio exec will show
up not happy with the director
for a style they're shooting in or unhappy
because a dp is moving the camera too much
and the the tempers that flare on set in front of
everybody I mean we are in a industry of children
whether we like it or not and I just I just
don't think it needs to be that way and I think
communication is key it's not just okay we believe
in you you're getting paid go shoot this movie
and then we look at dailies and we tell you what
we like and don't like and when you start doing
that to an artist it really the hair on the back
of their neck goes up I've seen it time and time
again and I just think there's I think there's
probably some basic fundamentals I find a lot of
suits spend a lot of time psychoanalyzing things
they take a lot of classes and body language
how to read somebody's temperament across the desk
or across the room and I don't think they've been
taught or maybe there isn't a class when you make
this the next book is basically how to understand
the inner workings of an artist and what those
buttons are in their life that can make them
because once that trust has
been broken or once that
that communication has been derailed I it's very
I don't think it's something that can come back
did it do the steeple with the hands
a lot of this a lot talking like this
am I doing that right now no no I'm just
I'm just thinking of like the any any good
movie with an executive or something you'll have
the steeple and they'll be thinking watch phil
watch phil joanna's film entropy I think it's a
brilliant film phil phil's a friend he directed
gridiron gang phil it's no secret phil punched out
a studio executive in front of 300 people on a set
of heaven's prisoner and I think it was heaven's
prisoner he did it was the alec baldwin film
and you watch what builds to that point and a lot
of people don't believe that actually happened I
can assure you it did and it happens more often
than you realize it may not go to blows as much
anymore I think people are ready for that now or
they they hide behind text and emails is really
what people are able to do it's that's also
a lot of the face-to-face has been taken out
of our business everything's text messaging and
emails and I think a lot of people do that out of
trying to get it done quick fear I think fear is
a big big component of that because people don't
like confrontation and I think if executives would
just understand that when you trust an artist's
vision and you greenlight him or her
to to fulfill that promise that you
you really need to just trust you sidney lamet
in his book said something brilliant about
hiring actors and he said when you're a
director and you make a decision on an actor
good or bad you have to live with that decision
and you have to do everything you can to see that
that journey is as smooth as sailing as
possible I can't remember the words he used but
there were times in his career where he said
that he really thought he had the right actor
for a role and realized on day one in rehearsal
that this was the biggest mistake of his life and
you would never know it as an audience member
you would never know it as maybe the actor who
he hired but it's it's about understanding
the being that you're working with and
artists are fragile we're very sensitive
to everything we take everything personally
if somebody doesn't like a cut or somebody doesn't
like the theme of something or the style it's it's
it's a personal attack it's never separated and it
takes a strong artist to be able to do that and I
think it takes a stronger executive to be able
to really find a way to communicate with people
on how to get the adjustments the studio
or network might need to get what they need
and I I've really seen it done in a productive
way that's just me sure and I agree with what
you're saying about being sensitive but I think
also too some of the quote unquote suits and I
wish I could find a better word for them but
they're also sensitive in that they don't like
being told no and they don't like people usurping
their authority or or challenging them especially
if they believe in this pecking order and there's
a lot of fear I think there's fear from both what
Hollywood fear and love okay so so fear fear from
both sides and so just thinking about what are
ways that there could we could prevent a blow-up
if if one is mirrored in a pecking order mindset
and well I can't believe you would tell me what to
do you don't who I am and then there's this artist
don't what I've done and I can't believe you would
doubt me and then the clash that happens yeah
it's ego driven at the end of the day I mean
it's fear driven and it's ego driven because in
our business it's it's literally your career could
be made or broken in in one project you're either
the next damian chazelle or you make a mistake
and you don't have a hit you're done I mean
look what happened to george cosmados he came
off of god rest him he's a great filmmaker I
mean look at what tombstone he did tombstone
and he was the next greatest thing and I worked
with him on shadow conspiracy with charlie sheen
which was I think the last film he ever did and
I can assure you that's not what he wanted
to go six feet under with his name on
and I don't think he would have worked much after
that film no disrespect but not saying I could do
anything better I'm just saying when you look at
how fast you can turn around you know some great
filmmakers and actors in this industry
that have hits that people just they're
just pulled over with and they do a couple more
films and what happens to them and it's unfair
one of my favorite filmmakers of all time
is mike vegas I mean I admire him because
here's a guy who writes directs produces edits
composes caters probably cleans the latrine
I mean that guy is a filmmaker's filmmaker and
obviously when he had leaving las vegas with
nicholas cage and elizabeth shu and all
the oscar accolades that came with it
how do you deny somebody like that this guy's
gonna do it again solomon king went through the
same thing he had a string of hits and then
had some that that weren't as successful and
and it's it's I guess it's like that in sports
it's like that in in a lot of businesses I mean
I don't know it seems like people can in the suit
side it seems like people can run companies into
the ground over and over again and still end up
running other companies but we see that a lot
but I think I think the artists and the
executives I think need to find a way
to to spend more time understanding one another
and not just thinking they understand one another
we forget that I always go back to the record
industry and and when when music was a business
back in the earlier days of a r representatives
working for labels and seeking bands and clubs
that nobody heard of and watching that that
machine grow into becoming something that was
worthy of signing to a major label I knew a lot
of a r guys back in the 80s and 90s because of
my music background and I used to say to them how
do you not get fired and they say we say no you
don't sign a band you don't get fired and studios
have to crank out so many films a year production
companies have to fulfill the machine especially
now because it's a bottomless pit right you know
how many productions are getting made at netflix
at any given time it's 33 I think right now
so there's a machine that needs to be filled
but I think they understand each other from
a very generic standpoint I still don't
think they've found a way to really melt
into harmonious relationships it's very rare it's
very rare about a year and a half ago Shane you
wrote a book entitled what you don't learn in film
school so if we proposed a sequel to this book
maybe what they don't teach you
after 20 years in the film industry
what would be the main crux of that
book oh that's a great question wow
I think as I talk about in the book
every day I learn something new every day
and I I've been producing for over 30 years and
I been in this industry 49 of them and every day
I learned something new and I think what's most
important is is whether you're on the executive
side or you're on the artistic side I think you
have to be open to change you have to be open to
learning from your mistakes and owning
them I think I don't think enough people
own their mistakes and I think we grow from
our mistakes instead of burying them and
having a fall guy or a scapegoat I think the
biggest thing that I see is people not learning
I think I think it goes back to putting your
pride aside I've i've come from a very humble
educational documentary film beginning and
then was very fortunate to to run a company
that did a lot of studio films and ultimately
doing gridiron gang and working with networks
and I have I have come back to being an indie
guy and and it's by choice I mean I don't know
maybe nobody wants me in Hollywood proper but I
didn't give them the chance to say they didn't I
just decided to go back to what I love but what
I see in a lot of the people that I that I come
in contact with or I work with that are trying to
find their way is I think they're more concerned
about public perception about what they do and
how they come off than actually doing the work
I find more people spend most of their time trying
to gloat about what they're doing on social media
and hey I get it it drives drives projects for
some people a lot of people are more interested in
having fake it till you make it or perception is
everything I get that I don't I don't endorse it
but I understand it and I think what what I
find interesting is some of these filmmakers
that I that I personally know will absorb a lot
of information whether it's from me or other
people that you've had on film courage or other
filmmakers that they know that have been through
the good the bad and the ugly and they love
taking the meetings but they don't apply it
and I'm just as guilty of it I'm not saying that
I have all the answers because I clearly don't
but I one thing I don't do is I'm I learned
to saying when I was in high school is even
a dumb dog doesn't look a hot stove twice I
try not to do that in what I do I try to learn
and make the next better even if it's just from a
production standpoint last time we were together
I was getting ready to do a film in the heat of
covid we shot that in november december october
november and december of last year in 2020 when
other projects were getting shut down we we took
over 400 coveted tests we didn't have one positive
we we had so much fun we had I always worked with
a small crew anyway they gave us with the mandates
from the union we we couldn't have more than 20
people on a set including cast and crew it was
the most fun I ever had making a movie in my life
and moving forward I've learned to take that
experience and how I can make the next project
better for for everybody and it wasn't
just about having a smaller crew or being
stuck doing three tests a week for covid it
was it was about I think there was a lot of
it was people were so happy to be back out
working and interacting with each other
but it reminded me again of the respect that we
need to have for one another how blessed we are
to be in this industry whether you're making
a 500 film or a 50 million dollar film we are
equally as blessed where we get to do something we
love and just trying to remind ourselves it's only
a movie I learned something from martin sheen a
hundred years ago we were doing a film together
and it shot over over the holidays and god god
bless him he he for some reason he didn't go back
for one of the holidays when everybody else broke
so it was it was adam kane martin sheen myself and
and I think it was susan mcguire our a.d and the
four of us went out to a holiday dinner in arizona
we were making a film and he told the story of his
heart attack on apocalypse now which everybody's
heard different versions of it I heard it directly
from him and I'm not going to relay the story I
wouldn't want to waste everybody's time on that
you can research it but the one thing mr sheen
said as he was being wheeled into the hospital for
his surgery after having his heart attack was his
wife jan leaned over and looked at him and said
it's only a [ __ ] movie martin and here at that
time they didn't know it was going to be one
of the most iconic films in Hollywood history
but when when he said that I never forgot it
because what we do is special to us and hopefully
the people that our work touches and people that
see it but in the grand scheme of life it's only a
movie and I try to remember that I try to remember
that when we go on set every day we're blessed to
be there have a smile you're not sitting in a
cubicle trying to raise money and make a movie
you're out making a movie and I and again it's
it's just I think the next book going back to
your question of an hour and a half ago karen I
think is it's bringing a sense of of joy and and
feeling blessed regardless of what it is you're
doing we all want to do bigger better things
at a bigger scale and get paid more for it
but it's not about that be in the moment
love the moment and realize that people only go
go to the moon once usually I don't think there's
many people have been to the moon twice and and
I look at every opportunity to shoot a film is
going to the moon and just enjoy the moment build
those relationships treat people that you the way
you want to be treated because the day is going
to come or that pa on your set is going to be
the guy running hbo or three arts entertainment
or something and and it's it's mind-blowing how
going back to what we talked about with suits
and artists it's the way people treat each
other especially in this business it's not always
favorable and I know I'm not perfect and I've i've
raised my voice and been upset with people and I
like to think I go back and make it right but I
think what i'd like to see people do is is build
more relationships and build more of a family
within their core not just look to get through
tuesday get the film done on time on budget move
on I think you look at some of the most successful
filmmakers that that have come through and
especially in the old days and there was a there
was a family when hitchcock made his films people
all stepped up and helped each other there wasn't
a divide when he was making psycho and he was sick
and was out for a week or two the ad directed the
film his wife stepped in and did some directing I
mean that's that's a family atmosphere and I wish
there would be more of that in our industry and
people weren't just interested in me me me I think
it's it's about us stronger together you think too
so if we if we took the first book film school and
everyone's about going out there making their mark
and when you're younger it's definitely more about
competition and wanting to prove yourself and then
maybe life has different knocks and different
things happen and it becomes more about meaning
and so maybe that's also something that's after
30 years it's more about what does this project
mean to me and and am I doing what I want to be
doing I think that's a big part of it I think that
if we can grow from everything we do I think
that's the key is growth and and trying to
build something special so the next one is
better and bigger doesn't mean it's going
to be financially bigger or financially better
but the experience and I think when you have
an atmosphere on a set that people feel a part
of regardless if they're the guys coming in once
a week to empty the toilets or the star of
the show if people feel a part of something
I think it really shows on screen we
talk about that a lot in the book is
temperament respect on a set and how it ultimately
is going to affect your actors they are such
sensitive beings their their antennas are way
out they're picking up on every nuance of of mood
the director and dp are pissed off at
each other an ad is upset or snippy they
they they pick up on that and I just I
think what I was trying to say earlier
is that I think I think everybody is truly in
our industry it's every man for themselves but
I think it it shows too much I think people need
to remember that it it takes a village it takes
it takes a unit we don't we don't storm countries
or go into war thinking about one or two people
we go in as a unit and I just would like to see
more of that in our industry what's your advice
to people on getting representation whether it's
for film screenwriting acting well I think that
having representation and how it comes to you
and the the need for it is they're separate you
have to keep them separate I think if you're
an actor you need it it's an agent's job is
to go through the breakdowns and submit you
for roles to get you taped auditions are in
the room I mean an actor can't act without people
knowing they exist I think that cinematographers
that's very important too I think agents can be
very beneficial to a cinematographer's career
by and large agents sit around wait for the phone
to ring I mean let's call it like it is the days
of agents reading scripts taking 20 or 30 home a
weekend and discovering new property and calling
an actor and saying I just read something
you've got to read let's call the producers
and tell them you want to do this a lot of agents
wait for the phone to ring and I think that when
writers directors and filmmakers ask about
getting representation I'm a firm believer that
you're either chasing it or it's chasing you and
I talk about this a lot in the book a big chunk of
it about representation and being a filmmaker and
I'm a firm believer that if if you're not making
noise with your work and you got to call agents
and people to represent you then your work is
not going to be something that they're going to
have a real easy time getting behind and selling
and I know that's very harsh to say look I've been
through 100 agents and managers and I've never
gotten a job from one not one and I've been with
some big agencies and big managers and maybe it's
my fault maybe I'm just horrible and unsellable
but I get asked a lot from from young writers
who may have had a short film made or producers
who are trying to sell sell what they're doing
to a bigger scale and things today especially with
the changes in our industry in the last few years
agencies that are respectable and real they
they're kind of signing people by committee
now it's not hip-pocketing the days of an agent
taking somebody kind of off the grid in their
back pocket and trying to do something with that
is is really frowned upon and is something that's
really not done as much anymore if at all so when
you go in with a with a resume and a body of work
that you might have and try to get representation
you you have to they're gonna check with everybody
from the janitor to the parking attendant
to make sure if they should sign you or not
it's it's not just somebody falling in love with
you and unless it's somebody who runs a boutique
on their own that they are the judge jury and
executioner but I have found that when when you
seek out representation and you have to kind of do
a tap dance to get them to want to get behind your
work and your abilities I always say let's see
where that that relationship is in six months
they usually don't bear much fruit and and that's
it's unfortunate it's hard to get representation
as a writer as a producer as a director in this
town that said it is not hard to create original
content that if it's good enough can get the
attention of a respectable agent or manager
again we we have endless resources for so cheap
as filmmakers even even student filmmakers you
can get a dslr you can get actors and again don't
hire your cousin and your mother to be in them go
to acting schools and call the people that run
these acting schools and say I'm making a short
I'm doing a spec commercial give me some
good talent there are people out there that
actually know how to act that you can
get and put stuff together if if your
hurdle is well I can't get anything done because
I can't get any money or I can't get anything
done because nobody's behind me then you have
to create the content and if you don't have the
content created how are people going to know if
you're worthy of being represented or not I'm not
trying to discourage anybody from trying to
get representation and I'm sure there are
those wonderful relationships where the artist has
banged down the door enough times and the agent
finally said okay i'll rep you and it's it's gone
well there are those exceptions but by and large
the majority of the time first-time writers
and I say first-time writers I finished a
screenplay or I have a book on amazon where's
my agent it doesn't work that way and if it does
let's see how that went after six months
I just don't think that when you have to
try to convince somebody to represent you
that that that's that's a passion I think
when a true agent or manager gets behind somebody
I think they have to be passionate about them
I think they have to be they're they're working
for the artist and they have they only get paid
on commission and who are they going to spend
their days banging down the doors for and if
if you're an actor I really believe you need
an agent but talking about the filmmaker side
it's tough to get representation and and I often
tell filmmakers don't don't spin your wheels and
burn your calories trying to get an agent
just the amount of time you're trying to
burn the phones to find an agent you should be
shooting something that's going to make an agent
say holy [ __ ] I saw this on youtube I saw
this on vimeo I saw this at a film festival
or at least if you are going to bang on
those doors you should have three or four
short films or something I know a very successful
commercial director who's who's been at the top
of the game for many years and I asked him once I
said how did you get in the game you didn't come
from film school you didn't have parents that
could he said hey man I got a camera I got I
got friends who could act I got guys who can hold
sound and I knew how to direct I knew how to cut
and I went out and I started doing spec
commercials like he did doritos coca-cola pepsi
he would just grab product and do these incredible
how like doritos would have these contests where
create your own create your own campaign and maybe
we'll use it he would just do that for everything
he would do cars like if his mom got a new bmw
mom let me let me make a car commercial for bmw
and this guy had like 20 or 30 commercials and
they all looked like really big commercials
and he was able to go in and say this
is what I can do this is who you're
representing keep in mind when you go to
an agent they need content to sell you
because they're going to make phone calls or
emails on your behalf and the decision makers are
going to say great let me see their work and if
you don't have work the agent's job you're kind of
you're kind of kneecapping the agent going in
because they're going to come to you and say
you got to get me content and it's it can't be
looked at as a chicken or egg type thing that's
an excuse the filmmaker the artist has to get out
there and and create the content now if you're a
writer I'm a firm believer that you may you may
excel or be passionate about writing one thing
I think it's important if you're unknown to really
stretch and try to try to get three or four spec
scripts done in different genres because there
are companies that are just making thrillers
that may read your script that an agent
can take to somebody like mar vista
and and say hey you're doing a bunch of stuff for
a lifetime look at this if the agent can get it
in the room it'll get a look but there's also
companies that only do horror there's companies
like hallmark that only do romantic comedies or
whatever those things are called and if if you're
a writer that's looking to get representation
the agent is going to want and need as much
ammunition as possible you have to make their job
easy and if you give them three or four different
a pallet of different things they're going to be
able to circulate three or four different scripts
and maybe 15 or 20 different companies think about
what the odds just come of you not only getting
somebody in your corner to represent you but
getting seen and getting a reputation a wonderful
woman I met a year and a half ago at a webinar
right when kovitz started brilliant writer she
writes these beautiful romantic little films that
are just hallmark and and and she got she got a
script read and she got a green light and she got
the film produced and now she's a working writer
and she we talked about it and she was
like oh my god I got genres in everything
this woman was pushing a genre but when it
came time to getting looked at and getting
representation she had a whole plethora of stuff
to give to them and say look I can write anything
and that's what she's doing now and you have to
I think too many of us sit around and wait for
the phone to ring or the door to get knocked on
or somebody to know somebody you have to be so
proactive on on creating content to get people
excited about what you do I go back to we talk
about films like napoleon dynamite started as
a short saw was a short sling blade was a short
there's there's so many of those films even
whiplash was a short they obviously did
something right to get the attention to get
these things made into major motion pictures
that hasn't changed people forget that those four
great films started from humble humble beginnings
I mean napoleon dynamite the short was in
black and white for crying out loud I mean
it's horrible but it was great but it was it was
so bad it was good right but that's how we have to
think as filmmakers james wan did it brilliantly
with his short for saw I mean I encourage
everybody go on youtube find these films they're
all there they're all there you can find these
shorts and you will see where billy bob thornton
got slingblade from you will see where napoleon
dynamite and whiplash all came from because
they're all they're all there and they all started
because somebody said screw it I'm gonna do it and
that's that's what I tell people they need to do
so maybe we are too much in this mindset of like I
need to have my people do it oh wait I don't have
people I need to get people I need to get people
I I'm I I'm not successful until I have people
and we're not willing to say wait a minute I'm
not there yet a lot of people have a hard time
saying I'm not there yet and that that's a really
good point karen we all have to be able to say
we're not there yet and truly identify and accept
when we're not and get over that next hump I mean
I deal with a lot of actors that when we do
workshops and and do acting class work and
it's awesome I need a team you need a team for
what you've had an agent for two years you go out
on 15 auditions a week you're not booking you need
to better the craft do you ever think maybe you're
just not good in a room do you ever think maybe
you need to study better and look at the reel
and half the time they're not off book and they've
had the work for three days and you're reading one
scene you're not off book yet these are the
kind of things that that really will impact
an actor from getting past an audition and it's
it's very hard for artists we are so myopic we
are so self-centered anyway it's in our nature
we we're very selfish people but when it comes to
getting to the next level it's very very
rare that somebody can look and say it's me
I need to get off my butt and create content I
need to get into acting class two or three nights
a week I need to go take a class in basic lighting
if I really want to be a cinematographer or a
director I need to understand lenses I need to I
tell everybody who wants to write produce direct
and and get in the edit bay that's where you're
going to learn it more than anything because
you're going to see you're going to fix other
people's mistakes you're going to you're going
to learn what ends up on a cutting room floor
you're going to realize the amount of time you
waste on a set and what that'll do is it'll
better you when you make your short films and
it'll better you when when writing scripts I mean
it's amazing how many writers have never been in
the edit bay that's the most important place
there are three scripts there's the one you
write the one that's shot and the one that's cut
and if you can if you can bridge the gap between
the one that's written and the one that's released
boy it's a it's a helpful tool and I know writers
are going to bash me for saying that but get your
button to write in the edit bay and and realize
what what you write and how it affects production
costs and putting certain amount of characters in
a certain scene and you got to remember you got to
cover all that get multiple takes on every actor
and and what that does production is a lot of
good we talk about this in other another webinars
I've done and the writer needs to understand a
production mindset because there are some great
scripts out there that that don't get read past 20
or 30 pages and it's because they don't understand
it from a producer view where you really have to
think about when you write a script you can say
well it shouldn't be that expensive it just takes
place in a flat new york and well okay how many
people are in it how many different locations what
is your logistics here and you have to think of
who you're going after realistically to produce
it and does it fit in what they're doing
it's about finding that connection
with a producer with your written word
but also kind of going back to what you said
making an agent's job easier if you have an
agent that isn't wme or caa level that's not going
to kick down doors and get you to every studio
you got to realize the level of the agent or
manager you're working with and where they
have the ability to get you now if you are able
to work with somebody and somebody is showing
interest in working with you I think it's very
important you have that talk early on is what is
your ability to get me through the door what are
the studios networks production shingles whatever
they call them where can you get my stuff read so
that artist that writer can understand okay this
manager can only get me in a hallmark so they need
to start thinking about okay let me get this stuff
together for you that's gonna give you the path of
least resistance start getting my my stuff to you
that you can go to hallmark with or is it lifetime
let me get you some thrillers let me get you some
husband came out of jail wants to see his
kid scripts let me give you some of those and
and that's that's important it's not just about
being a good writer it's about finding a match
and finding out who your potential representatives
have the ability or juice to get to so the work
that you submit to them it resonates with the
people that it's ultimately going to get read by
because if you have a great script and the people
that are reading it have no business making a film
like that or no interest in making a story like
that it doesn't matter it's just wasted time
what if someone says though that I'm not a diy
person like that I I want my I I'm kind of grew
up with staff and different things so I need I
need to have my people do this well if you've
grown up with staff you should be able to write
checks so write check and go make a movie I mean
that's fine I mean I'm sorry but yeah I think
you're in the wrong business I mean it's it's
very rare that somebody can sit in a basement
and just crank out scripts and the day is
going to come where that script is read by the
right agent to the right assistant to an actor and
I mean there's always the lottery I mean people
win the lottery that's true I think the odds are
about the same but I think you need to if you're
not diy and you need people and you need a staff
then what I think you need to do is find other
people that are needing a staff but one of them
has a camera and one of them is an actor and one
of them may be an editor and work together we
talked earlier about people working together and
building something special and building building a
team everybody having a common goal to get to the
next level and that's what I tell a lot of writers
I said the cool thing about being a writer is
you don't need anybody to tell you to go to work
you really have the only job in this industry that
you you may not get paid yet or at all but nobody
can tell you you can't work right now you have the
ability to roll out of bed turn on a light at two
in the morning and write and that's a beautiful
thing because an actor is not going to be able
to get in front of a camera and tap dance unless
there's a script director doesn't have anything to
direct unless there's a script there's nothing
to produce without a script the writers are
essential I mean it's so important I mean it's an
incredible position to be in if you're not able to
be a writer producer director editor or filmmaker
and all your focus is on writing then you need to
get out more and you need to find people of like
mind that have those skill sets or the materials
to get your products seen it's just it's not gonna
sitting in a pdf on an external hard drive or
somewhere on your computer is not going to get
it made it's about getting it with people and
I'm very big a lot of people like to talk
about pitch decks and proof of concept some
of the most impressive things I've seen are when
people go out and shoot a scene or two or three
to me that's a real pitch deck that's
a proof of concept I don't want to see
papers and comps and actors you're never going
to acquire on your proof of your your pitch deck
I want to see you go out and shoot a scene for
your film with comparable qualified people and
people that are passionate about it and I
think some of those true pocs that I've seen
they knock me out of my seat I can't believe
what people are putting together these days
and and I mean for nothing no money there's no
excuse if you're not pissing someone off you're
not being heard sure what's the logic behind that
well I think I think that as as artists I think
we're all looking for our voice I think we're all
looking to to turn heads and if you kind of just
fall into the norm and you just kind of do what
everybody thinks you should do you're not gonna
you're not gonna get the attention you deserve
you think about the films that have truly been
game changers or the songs or the other works of
art it's because people were weren't afraid to
think outside of the box or think left of left
and and change scares people we talked earlier
about fear especially with the executives
in this industry and I just think that
if we're coming off of a time where there's been
so much hatred passed back and forth especially on
social media between different sides of the
fence right and at the end of the day we're
all humans we need to we need to unite but what
what is apparent is if you just follow like sheep
and just kind of go about your merry way you're
just you're gonna you're gonna fit nicely into a
mold and they're gonna compartmentalize you and I
think some of the artists that I've respected most
they're not afraid of pissing people off and
making change and making success come their way
because they weren't afraid to to rub people the
wrong way they weren't afraid to give somebody the
big fu and say I'm doing it this way and I don't
need your money I don't need your distribution
we're just gonna go do it I mean robert rodriguez
is a classic example dennis hopper when him and
peter fonda went out and did easy rider some of
the people that I admire as filmmakers I mean
looking at somebody like hal needham who came from
a tough stuntman background and understood the
workings of how to make a movie breaking them down
from shot to shot to working with the editors the
producers the directors the actors the stuntmen
and finally just woke up one day and started
making these great movies and I'm inspired most
by rebels I'm inspired most by people that weren't
afraid if people were going to approve doesn't
mean you're going to be successful but I think
I think there's certain things as artists
that that we have a responsibility to do
I mean art is what changes the world movies movies
Hollywood songs they they set the tone for culture
they change trends like that and that's exciting
to me and what when you hear me say if you're not
pissing people off you're not being heard well
if you're just falling into what everybody else
is doing you're just falling into what everybody
else is doing quentin tarantino became who he was
because he did things his way he he was willing
to roll the dice and fortunately found people
that were willing to roll the dice with him robert
rodriguez mike figgis we talked about him earlier
dennis hopper i'll need him I mean some of these
great filmmakers that just they're not afraid to
rub people wrong they're not afraid to piss
people off they're not afraid to fail they're
going to go down and a ball of flames are going
to do it their way but man if it works watch out
and that just is kind of that mindset so maybe
it doesn't mean deliberately trying to piss
people off but but knowing that they're going
to be people that are going to be offended or a
they themselves feel they can't do that so
they don't want you to do it because absolutely
their social structure wouldn't approve them oh
absolutely I mean I can't tell you how many times
I would get calls from people that I had
produced with in the past that would say to me
I I'm really concerned that this investor may
go on imdb and see some of the things you've
done in the past whether it was with zalman
king or charlie sheen or whatever and I'm like
yeah okay so what's the problem if they've had a
pretty good run and it's this fear and of maybe
certain people would be nervous or whatever and
I never understood that I would always ask him to
please explain that to me charlie somebody
I was very proud of having a history with
in my career and is very instrumental
in getting me to where I am in my life
and for somebody to come along and and be
nervous about the rebellion of of a charlie
sheen or a bad boy and and somebody who who
made some of the most incredible erotic cinemas
almond king and those are people that basically
gave people the middle finger and did what
they wanted to do I mean one of my favorite
solomon king stories and we didn't talk about
this before we talked about suits and artists
was I remember working with zalman on a film
and an executive from the studio was there we
were on the other side of the world we were
in bali indonesia and there was somebody there
telling him how something had to be done and he
oh absolutely it went through this whole dog
and pony show that was so unsolvent at the time
and the guy left you just turn around and
goes [ __ ] him he goes watch how we do this
and he goes you got to remember something he goes
if you're going to if you're going to do something
you do it your way you just got to learn how to
tap dance and tell people what they want to hear
so they give you the opportunity to do it
because remember if you screw up you're done
but if you're successful they'll take
the credit for it but you'll work again
and that's that's kind of it I just
I just I went through a phase where
I was getting calls from a lot of I don't know
more prim and proper entities that weren't much
into the mentality of just going out and
doing what you want to do everything was
very structured everything was very formulaic
which is not something that I fall well into
and I just found that there was a lot
of things that they were trying to
to reshape or curb or kind of protect from
certain people they were involved with knowing
it's like well there is something called the
internet it's all out there but my point is is
that I learned really quickly that there there
are a lot of people that as you said it's fear
they they're afraid of being looked at as a rebel
or somebody likes to kick the dirt or whatever
and I personally don't don't care I personally
don't care do what you want do what you love
love what you do and and do what feels right
in here as long as you're not hurting anybody
and if it pisses people off say the video well
good I'm glad I got some free rent in your head
you think people are scared of that
personality type because it can't be controlled
I think there's I I think it's not about trying
to be rebellious or being controlled I think
yeah there's a lot of people that want to
try to conform you especially as artists
into what they want you to be or what their
end game is I think a lot of there's so many
intricate parts in filmmaking there are people
that bridge the money together with the product
and then the product with the artist and then the
artist with the output and there's so many people
that have to be kept happy and again it goes back
to I think executives and artists being able to
learn how to communicate better better lines of
communication and understanding each other better
but I think that there's a lot of fear and and
we've been fortunate in working with people in
in our circle that the decision makers that come
at our end who are the ones writing our checks
they they love what we do they get what we do
and they trust us and they say we're doing this
because we believe in you we're doing this because
we like what you do and what you represent so go
do it and and that's it doesn't matter if they're
giving you five dollars for a film or five million
for a film it's just about working with people who
understand you and if if you're a true artist and
there are things that you want to express there's
things that you want to experiment with I think
you need to respect yourself enough to do that
I'm all for doing work to get paid that we've
all been works for hire things that we wouldn't
put on our resume or maybe things that we're
not excited about there's nothing wrong go work
every time you work you're going to learn every
time you get another credit you'll put some
groceries away in the in the cupboards and
you get to eat and it's fun you get to pay rent
and all that fun stuff but I think you also have
to remember to allow yourself that freedom and
to be able to do that and I think yeah there's
a lot of people that are afraid I know I was
working with somebody in the past that was
working with some entities that were not exciting
to me and there was there was a concern about
what I represented as a filmmaker what my attitude
is and making the films that I want to make and
where they were thriving and other networks and
other outlets that were like oil and water and
I finally got to the point I was like you got to
pick a side you're either going to you're going
to do what I do or you're going to keep doing that
which no disrespect that's that's cool pays your
bills but if you're going to come here you're
not going to stifle what I do hoping that these
other entities are not offended because you're
affiliated with me I don't embarrass anybody
I'm not gonna kill puppies or beat children but
there is certain types of mentalities mindsets and
content that we make that may not fit on the
family channel and that's just not kind of
content I want to make so yeah I think there's a
lot of people who try to stifle and try to conform
artists into being what they want them to be for
the wrong reasons and that's that's to me is that
can be very dangerous for the artist did you watch
the queen's gambit I actually did I was afraid
you're gonna ask me if I saw something which I
didn't see oh okay thank you thank you for not
asking if I saw bridgerton okay sure so so forgive
me I'm blanking on the character's name but thomas
brodie sanctuary sangster if I hope I'm saying his
name right so the one that's like this rebel chess
player who kind of saunters him he's kind of the
james dean right yeah and then once you finally
get to know him he's actually a sweetheart but he
has this mystique and this persona of this bad boy
chess player amongst some very cookie cutter
intellectual overthinking stanford graduates
right exactly smart people smart people but but
also very invested in their identities as smart
people yeah and so this guy comes in and he's
just like this you don't know what to make of them
you're fascinated by them but anyway so I
just it kind of reminds me of that I just
that's a great analogy it was a great show we
really enjoyed that I think like the rest of
the world we caught that during covet we didn't
buy a chess set afterwards but yeah and I think
there are ways and I hate to keep bringing them
up and and I owe so much of my career to zulman
zalman king if you don't know who he is look him
up zolman took me under his wing 25 years ago
and I learned more from my my years with zalman
than anybody and zalman was a true rebel I mean he
was a golden globe nominated actor turned writer
who wrote nine and a half weeks with his wife
and and went on to direct some of the most
incredible incredible cinema and nobody told a
story through a lens like solomon nobody could and
the careers he launched and discovered are endless
whether you talk about mickey rourke or kim
bassinger david david duchovny and just that the
list goes on and on and on and my point is solomon
had a relationship his partner was it was a man
who I still am very close to by the name of david
saunders david david was running one of the the
sub studios under sony when peter gruber was there
and zalman and this suit became friends and they
wound up creating red shoe diaries and launching
show timing that was really their first series
and built an empire on this this incredible
series starring a guy that nobody knew about
called david duchovny that just opened the letters
and read them and read them to his dog usually and
made these incredible women empowering
erotic cinema the relationship that I
most admired of all the relationships I've
known in Hollywood was solomon and david
and just talk about mutt and jeff apples and
ford trucks ying and yang and boy were they
were they that's the kind of relationship
executives and and artists should have because
they they conquered the world I mean you may not
like what they did but they conquered the world
yeah I think each needs each other because
because one is going to have one skill set
that the other doesn't have and vice versa
and absolutely one will be organized one
will be sort of a beautiful yeah and they
need each other and they really they really
fed off of one another and there was nobody better
in the room they would fight like cats and dogs
I remember david duchovny said when solomon
passed that he was a true artist he'd think
more about the curtains in the room and the color
and the sheen they would give off off a certain
light at the certain time of day he would shoot at
zollo would focus on that for hours and then want
something painted a certain color and dave would
come in and say whoa whoa whoa back up how much
money are you spending on painting these things
how much you spending on this fabrics element well
well that's that's insane you can't do it they'd
fight well then ethan I'm not doing a movie david
like me sorry Shane movie's canceled have a
good life I just slowly go for a walk I knew
they'd fix it and they always did they did that
almost every day but they were an incredible duel
duo and that's the kind of relationship that I
wish for artists to have with somebody because
they they really david was the business and
zolman was the artist and boy did they just
they were amazing is it a producer's job to
gather ip well I would think so I mean you know
you know neil moritz who who is the the
master behind fast and the furious you
think about how that that incredible franchise was
birthed off of an article in the back of the metro
and the la times I think it was a metro section
or valley section about subculture of street
racing and those cars and that's what a great
producer does is they comb articles a lot of lazy
ones like to watch 2020 or dateline those things
usually don't get made into movies if they do they
they only go so far I find that some of the
great producers that I've been fortunate
enough to know are the ones that would
give me the time of day to at least talk to
it's these these these guys are on the hunt they
are constantly looking for a needle in a haystack
whether it's neil moritz or david hayman or david
zillon I mean they're just constantly looking
looking and looking for that thing that just
knocks them over and I think good producers
don't wait for it to come to them I think
it's a producer's job to I we talked about
the music industry earlier what made what made a
great record executive and it was the ones that
went to the nightclubs the roxy the whiskey and
the gizarri's at two o'clock on a monday night
and watch that headlining band on a monday or
tuesday that's that's where bands like van halen
were found and I know I know their history but I'm
just saying that they were signed off of a really
crappy attended night on the strip on a weeknight
and I think producers need to be more proactive
I think we we have gotten to the point where
it's we are so used to everything being at our
fingertips we can research everything we instant
gratification and I think the days I mean there
I remember when when I knew neil moritz years
ago long before we did gridiron gang together
I never saw neil without scripts I mean every time
you saw neil he had scripts he was always reading
that guy was just constantly he was a sponge
for content and it paid off look at the career
he's had I mean the guy's doing everything and
it's about finding those those books that nobody
has the rights to that you that you see wow this
can this this ip can change the world and i'd be
careful if if it's successful it's probably owned
but I think there are some gems out there that are
waiting to be found that it's always nice when
a producer especially somebody younger or newer
or somebody who may be more green or not
have the deep pockets that some of these
these folks have to be able to find something and
create it and and get it made but I think it's
it's a producer's job that's if you're going
to produ there's two kinds of producers there's
they're the ones that find the ip raise the money
get the distribution and the stars attach and
then there's the the producers that are more
line producers that are on the film that are
hiring the crew and getting the locations
and getting all the vendors and gear and
everything done but when you talk about a producer
who is going to do the suit side of the job
if you will I think it's just so important to just
be a sponge be open to anything and everything you
just never know where you're gonna find that
that that thing and how would one know if
the rights are owned whether it's life story
rights or there's actually a script or yeah in
acquiring property is several different ways you
can do it I mean if one of the one of the biggest
passion pieces I have that I swear I'm going to
get made before I die is the kelly sutton story
I mean here's a woman who held the speed record
at daytona who's living with multiple sclerosis
I mean she was supposed to die when she was eight
years old she's cheated death seven times I think
she's been a widow three times over her story is
unbelievable I was shooting a documentary in in
wyoming in montana when the whole world was on
fire up there back in like a 102 and I was sitting
in a holiday inn and we were we were basically
being kept in a hotel because of the fire danger
and I had nothing to do the tvs were out the
electricity was out and I went to the lobby of
the hotel and I found this sports illustrated and
there was a tiny little sub article you could read
through the magazines and they've sometimes got a
little sub something on the side and and it said
she'll she'll stop at nothing that was the name of
the article and it was about kelly girl sutton and
it was three paragraphs from paragraphs along
it was the most incredible piece i'd ever read
I got home I reached out to the family to
nascar I found her the internet wasn't as
amazing back then was able to find her talk
to her parents got in touch with kelly flew
out to a race watched her race a nascar
event and such a wonderful human being
and one of the one of the most delightful
business relationships I've had I feel like
we've failed we haven't gotten the filmmade
yet we came very close a couple times had a
green light at a network that an agent was good
enough to ruin agents are good at that but that
when you find somebody's story that you want
to tell if you're a producer I think the most
important thing that you you need to do is is is
be humble a lot of people in our industry go to
people with hype and pomp and circumstance with
all the promises and well look when somebody's
story is breaking news like the little girl
that fell into well 30 years ago every studio
in hollywood's going to try to get that so step
aside you're not getting those rights chances are
but if you find something that you like as an
article in the back of a three-year-old sports
illustrated or you see a piece on tv or you caught
a news segment I always say reach out as humble as
possible and just say look I fell in love with
your story I want to tell your story and I want
to see it's told in a way that you can be proud
of that will represent you and your family and
just go in with with with a servant's heart I've
been fortunate to to own a lot of intellectual
properties of life rights whether it was rick and
dicky hoyt story or the great iron gang that's one
that we had it's just it's about being kind it's
about being gentle it's not about selling the hype
a lot of people go into those things not realizing
that the people that they're approaching are not
Hollywood people so they're very off put by
our energy often whether we call it passion or
pomp and circumstance or just a
bunch of [ __ ] I don't know but
we tend to go in on 10. a lot of these
people have often just gone through
a pretty dramatic situation in their life or
a pretty extraordinary situation they're being
courted by all sorts of people or getting all
sorts of press that they're not used to and I
think it's important to remember that these people
are not of our world in business there are ways to
try to penetrate their their
their world and not be intrusive
great way to get ip though is to scour articles
oh articles datelines 2020s you get to a point
that where a lot of executives will start hearing
things and they'll say it sounds like a dateline
it sounds like a 2020 story things are probably
better served there but there are some remarkable
stories that come out of them there really are I
mean I fell in love with the bruce murakami story
I don't think everybody remembers that where poor
gentleman was his his wife and two children got
into a minivan and went to the store and they were
they were t-boned by a street racer killed a wife
and two kids and the kid was going to go to prison
and bruce stepped in and asked for mercy from the
court it was the ultimate story of compassion and
trying to change a life instead of sending a 16
year old kid to prison for 10 years I'm going
to take this kid under my wing I'm going to and
I saw it on dateline or 2020 like 20
years ago bruce flew out met with him and
I really liked bruce a lot but he was also being
courted by everybody else film ended up getting
made I think with dean kane and lifetime or
something but it was it was one of those things
you knew it was going to get made it's interesting
but yeah it's about you're basically pitching
you as a filmmaker we talk about writers going
into the roman pitching and you may not be a
writer if you're a producer but you have to meet
the family or the survivors people that have gone
through some extraordinary circumstances and try
to pitch them on feeling comfortable with you
I mean you're selling them on you and your
game plan and your tone and temperament
when did you realize you had to transition away
from screenwriting I was horrible at it I mean
it wasn't I just I I worked as a screenwriter for
a number of years I was very fortunate I was more
passionate about being on set and working with
people I'm a people person at the end of the
day it's one of my many faults and when you're
a writer you're you're isolated you're locked up
and you're that way too as an editor which I still
get stuck doing but it's it's more interaction
but I just I just got to the point that I as I got
older and realized where my passions were and my
energies were and my strengths and weaknesses were
writing just I started working with people I work
a lot with cj wally I just when I read his work it
made me want to make movies again I was I was done
I was ready to phone be done do the book
go teach I had a teaching opportunity at a
university to come in and I read a script that
cj wrote and I said this guy makes me want to
keep making movies and I realized that
this this guy can tell the stories that
kind of stories I want to tell and
we collaborated really well together
and it's exciting when you read somebody's
work that inspires you to keep going because
I was I was tired I had been beating
a bag a long time and kind of thought
I've been very fortunate I've been very blessed
I made my mark good bad and different I made a
mark may have been a stain in some people's eyes
but I made one and I wanted to teach and inspire
and encourage the next generation and and I just I
just felt that the amount of time it took to write
and it wasn't allowing me to make a film a year
or two films a year the way I wanted to and it's
great to work with somebody who understands and
gets me knows how to write for schedule and budget
we want to tell the same stories
I don't need to do that anymore
what's it like having written and
developed your own work now hiring
writers or partnering with other writers to tell
those stories well it's it's nice to be able to
focus on on certain things and not spread out too
thin write produce direct edit get the financing
all that stuff it's it really is it's a taxing
business I mean this business will eat you up
even if you have one job and spending the years
writing and developing something and trying to
get it financed and get it produced it takes a
lot of time and and I kind of go back to having
the ability to work with somebody who we we both
want to tell the same stories we both want to make
fun action comedy action thriller female driven
let the guys sit in in the passenger seat let the
girls drive make these fun films and we we both
love the same kind of movies we're both inspired
by the same kind of movies going back to like the
old hal needham films dirt movies and fast cars
race against time cannonball run smoking a bandit
and it's just it's easy it's it's it's almost
like we don't it's like hey we're gonna line up
to do another one what do you think about this
interesting okay what if we did that it's a
very simple process that the long part of it
is cj in our situation cj will just go through the
whole breakdown and develop development notes and
basically block it out and then once that's
done the scripts come very fast it's a very
fast process like we did double threat that was
created in mid-september we were shooting that
by october 15th I mean we had a script in six
days we all knew the story we wanted to tell it
was just about going out and rolling a dice during
covet and doing and as I said earlier was the most
fun I've ever had making a movie and I hope I hope
that translates on the screen we had a lot of fun
how many writers do you have
working for you now I work with
cj wally is is my point we're doing a lot of stuff
together right now but I'm a big fan of wt smith's
work we've we've done some specs together over
the years I think he's such a brilliant writer
he's poetic and every breath and every every
space between a word is just it's it's magic
he's a brilliant writer nicole faire brother is is
a writer that I was fortunate enough to find she's
up in canada she's a lovely writer I'm a big fan
of her work I hope to do stuff with her someday
but right now I'm primarily working with
cj because we have a slate of projects
that we're doing that we have a commitment on
that we have to do and it's exciting it's fun
how many years have you worked with the
same writers well I I've worked with
with w.t smith off and on for like 10 years we've
collaborated he's he's done some amazing work and
I've worked with cj now I think we're going
on year I think we're hitting year four
three or four I see I see working with writers
it's like a marriage it's a lot a lot like a dp
in a director's relationship I think if you if
you start it off in in a certain synchronicity
carry that out through the end and cj's become a
producer partner he doesn't just write but he's
so involved in what we do and we cut the films
and I like getting him involved because as we
talked about earlier I am a firm believer there
are three scripts there's the one that's written
the one that's shot and the one that's cut and
we we get every time we get closer and closer
to writing a cut film but there's also a respect
factor that I have it's funny when we first met
he was shocked that I wanted him to come out
from london to be on set when we did break even
like why wouldn't the writer be there and the
writer's standpoint was well we're never invited
out it's we got the script we got what we
wanted from you thank you you'll see the
film when it's done and I just think when
somebody births something creates something
I think they become a very important part
of the entire process I think it's a respect
level there are times where we have to cut
films down because of distribution deals where
television is going to only allow so much
time we're not getting 3 500 screens we're not
quentin tarantino we can make these three hour
movies about Hollywood or whatever and I love
his work I'm just saying that you don't have that
ability we have to keep our films under 95 minutes
well you shoot the script and you
glue it together and you've got
two hours you got 30 minutes you got to rip
out who better to ask than than than the writer
at first to say hey look we're 30 minutes over
man let's start talking about what can go instead
of just hacking it away and maybe not being as
sensitive to some of the nuances or subtleties
that were planted early on and I made that mistake
in not involving a writer on those edits and
that's something that I wouldn't do again it's
just sometimes the distributors come in and say
well we love it we're going to take it out but
you got to shorten it by 20 minutes and you just
you're in a hurry everybody thinks they know where
the best places to hack are I think it's good
to involve the writer smart we understand your
strategy is to develop a log line and a synopsis
and will you try to pitch investors first or
the distributors you're asking me personally um
i often will come up for me a title is important
I get stuck in a mud without a cool title
my movies may suck but our titles are cool and
I need that that gives me some fuel we know the
stories we want to tell and synopsises we come up
with a with an idea what what's what's our idea
what's the story and that inspires it and we
just start who who are the players who are the
protagonist antagonists who are the what's the
hero's journey what are their what are their
pitfalls and hurdles gonna be what's what's
the ticking time bomb what's gnawing at them
and then we we go through it and break it down and
start doing our development notes and and when I
get excited about it I call our investors and
I say we're ready we're ready to go and we know
the story we want to tell and usually it's
just a paragraph that they want from us
th that's at least in our situation that's
what we do we we get to do what we want to
do we're very fortunate so we there's it's it's
pretty much coming up with the story we want to
tell and going and doing it and and let chips
fall where they may it kind of comes back to
doing things the way you want to do them and
not not allowing people to tell you how to
do things or why do you think we're open to
suggestions and stuff but we tell the stories
we want to tell and we cast the people we want
to cast and we make the movies we want to make
and we don't ask for permission so if the title
is very important to you how much back and forth
and disagreements have you had over titles
and has that put the kibosh on the beginning
it's already cut off titles have never
been a problem that's that's one thing
that I often come up with the film
that we're starting in september we
we we had about a five second clash on a
title there were two titles that we both liked
and we're going with the other one and the more
I think about it the more cool I am with it but
titles it's never been a problem I just
when I was writing I needed a title I
needed a title to get excited if I didn't have
I couldn't be I couldn't get excited about it
I needed to get excited about blowing smoke I
need to get excited about double threat I need to
get excited about breakeven I needed once I had a
title I can just that's all I need and I can just
I'm all in give me that title and I'm all in at
least in my world it's just so important to me
it's everything it's everything and it doesn't
mean my titles are great but at least to me they
are right I mean we all love our children so the
untitled Shane stanley project is not going to
work for you no you can't no get out of bed at
2 am to start typing for that no no does not
there are there are no untitled Shane stanley
scripts or projects I promise you it has to
have a title if it's going to get the time
of day from me yeah it's really important
and you seem to like shorter titles or no I
think they're easier for people to remember
I I mean I I'm not saying all the titles
that I've had are winners at the end of
the day but I learned early I did a couple
of films with avi lerner back in the day and
because he sold globally titles were so important
I learned that titles have to translate globally
we can come up with the greatest title in
the world if that doesn't translate into
14 different languages it's not a good title
and that's really important and something that
people can remember something that people
say often people say I break even they're a
double threat oh he's just blowing smoke those
are the kind of titles that that appeal to me
a lot that's just me personally but I remember
that I remember when I was working with avi
when blockbuster and Hollywood video were still a
thing he used to say when you come up with a title
it's important to remember people are going
to start at new releases at a and they're
going to work their way to z most people
are done choosing by the time we get to m
which is funny our most successful film was with
an n no code of conduct with avi but that was
just kind of his model in coming up with titles
so I never forgot that and people laugh at me
when I throw that out because I like blockbuster
what and it's different now because everything's
on a thumbnail everybody's checking stuff
online or gets promoted and doesn't matter but
that was obvi's mentality and you think about
the success avi lerner has had over the last
30 or 40 years as being one of the most
prolific independent filmmakers in history
okay that's some advice I learned from avi that's
one thing i'll take away from that relationship
yeah so titles are important something catchy
quick simple what is the three billboards outside
of ebbing's montana I mean but that worked
it worked but what did everybody call it
I don't know three billboards okay yeah you see
throw both three that's a tongue twister right
had you seen billboards yet that's what I remember
yeah do you always go to a distributor first with
your idea I run it buy them i'll run it by him I
have a good relationship with with a distributor
that that we have and I just tell them this is
what we're doing I mean I I don't mean that I just
I we go make the films we want to make people
can catch it or they they don't have to we're
at a point where I don't care if it's it's going
in the dirt with 50 grand and a couple of stolen
cameras and we're going to shoot our movie
fortunately we haven't had to do that yet but I
would that's what we were going to do with double
threat during covet we literally had 50 grand
offered to us to do something during covid and
we were we were all in and we got fortunate and
one of our backers was excited to hear we wanted
to do something and said no let's let's do it
right but that's our mentality we just want to
make movies go find a home they'll find a home
so it takes time to get to that point and it's
it's it's just being able to do the things you
want with the people you love and the people that
are behind you whether they're writing the check
or putting the film out get what you do and they
know what they're gonna they know what to expect
with us they know what they're gonna get so it's
I talked to a distributor the other day and it was
oh you're making a movie when do you
start september 28th oh would you
do you want to tell us what this one is oh I can't
sure that was a discussion we're making it anyway
hope you enjoy it will you ever have a full
screenplay written when you pitch distributors or
only the idea I'm not gonna talk to a distributor
until I'm financed so I mean that's just me
personally I I'm not gonna waste anybody's time
I'm not gonna call an actor I'm not going to call
anybody until we're at this point where
it's like okay yeah we can make a movie
often who reads scripts anymore I mean you
can't get agents to read them lord knows they
don't do that are distributors really going
to read a script no they want to see a dumb
movie they want to know what you're doing
they're just going to throw it to somebody
for coverage and if you're making your movies
based on coverage I think that's a bad thing
some of the greatest movies in history got covered
so poorly some of the worst moves in history
are some of the greatest coverage films I mean
it's it's it's who's reading and who's covering
sometimes coverage is done out of respect while
somebody will say well we want to take this out
we'd like to take a look at it and get some
coverage on it okay and they usually call
back so you checked all the boxes it's it's fine
go go have fun go do it but that's it's not how
we make movies it's it's not about committee it
takes a team but we our job is to make the film
and it's not our job to distribute or sell it and
we have a mutual respect where what you're going
to get when we do something and I know what
to expect from you when you're going to put
it out and I won't tell you how do you do your job
let me do mine and that's the relationships that
we like to have with our distributors and sales
agents and it's just it's just it comes from time
time and time it's been beating the bag
for producing films for over 30 years you
you can get to a situation with some people that
are willing to trust you and it's about trust
it's about doing films and another reason I'm
an indie rat is I like I don't I don't put our
investors at risk make the movie for what it can
get made for so the the the stakes are low so
people aren't you're not ending up wearing cement
shoes in two years because couldn't give something
away that cost millions of dollars it happens all
the time that's not how we make our movies we make
our movies we punch way above our weight class
we we weigh our kick our punk coverage on these
things we get great cast great crew we make them
look as good as we can it's a roger corman idea
it's the same mentality I mean how many films did
roger corbin kick out it's it's just about doing
what we love and getting them done and having fun
and giving giving people content that's our job
and I don't like to over complicate it I will I
will never go to a distributor without a script
I mean there's nothing to talk about if there's
no money I don't talk to them until it's it's
we're financed we're ready to go and then
we're making it that's just that's just
the timeline of what we do now when you were
making movies with charlie sheen at that time
how much did it cost to make them and how much
were the distributors paying you for the movies
back when we were doing those we were an
independent company that that kind of decided to
do its own content it's kind of the early working
with some of the majors but getting a real taste
of independent filmmaking we were really in a
fortune fortunate situation because charlie was
a movie star he had just come off things like
terminal velocity and shadow conspiracy and
the arrival and his incredible catalog
of work and so we we had the avi learners
coming to us saying we'll we'll give you up
to 10 to 12 million to go make a movie and so
they weren't distributors that were buying them
they were people like avi that obviously would
smart businessman he would he would cast
it with real players and go sell it at
can or afm before we even shot a foot
of film I remember we went to cannes
for the 50th anniversary and they put us up at
the hotel do cop and we had a press conference
and it was mock artwork of the film with charlie
sheen mark de coskos joe lando martin sheen and
they pre-sold that thing globally I'm sure for
a lot more than they gave us to make it the film
did very well miramax dimension actually ended up
picking it up and they made some good tv deals on
it and we made the film for 12. we actually made
it for nine because we shot it in arizona at the
time they at the time had a 30 rebate so we got
I think three million back in actual cash rebate
wasn't tax incentives it was cash rebate and
that's how movies used to be made especially in
such a huge home video market that was the height
of blockbuster and Hollywood video and all those
great brick and mortar mod pasta stores were just
they they were printing money because of the home
video market and dvds coming out blu-ray hadn't
hit yet so they were giving us a lot of money we
were making some of these indie films for 8 to 12
million those were good times those were really
good times how much easier was it to make movies
in the 90s well I don't know if it was easier
there when we were making them the budgets were
big we were able to kick out a couple a year
and again the home video market was so was so
big you were able to get territories to put
up a lot of money around the globe for the home
video market tv rights foreign theatrical things
have changed substantially I find it easier
to make movies now because we're able to make
movies for a lot less I mean we're shooting all
those movies on panavision 35 millimeter cameras
that camera package to rent that film to
to buy and process and tell us any and
convert to video digital format so you can cut
it on your avids which back then cost 180 000
it movies were expensive back then we weren't
making them for cheap it's just and we were
doing independent films and I cringe today when I
hear about independent movies that are like five
million dollars I think that's no indy five
million dollars in today's economy be great
that the toys that we have that we can make movies
for but back then we were doing the indies for
eight to 12 million what should a filmmaker use to
determine a budget whatever he can get and I mean
that I I'm a big proponent of what's your budget
who cares I so many of us it's it's about a budget
you can get it broken down six ways till sunday
10 different line producers break it down budget
it you can use all your different pay scales with
the unions and whatnot that's all that's all going
to be black and white but at the end of the day
what's stopping you from getting the movie made
so for me I don't think about what a budget has
to be I think about I always put my investor first
I always think what's going to put he or she at
the lowest risk how do we execute this to the
best of our ability so we can out kick our punt
coverage we can now punch our weight class puts
put it all on the screen and wow people for a
fraction of what people think we actually made
it for that's just my mentality doesn't mean it's
right for everybody so when I look at a project
an investor calls me and says we're ready to go
or I call them and say I'm ready to go what's your
comfort level for the next season and they tell
me I say okay this is how much we have what can we
do with this I kind of go into it bass backwards
and I just I watch filmmakers time and time again
not get movies made because they've set some some
budget in their mind and unless you're being given
the money by a studio or a network who is really
governing that that's what the budget has to be
my father tried for four years to get
desperate passage made he had a million
dollar budget back in 1980 well it started in 82.
so a million dollars was a lot of money back then
finally in 1985 86 he got 25 grand to go make
the movie that was cutting really short to the
chase on this story and my my mother my father
and I with a couple of tight filmmaker friends
we we huddled together and figured out how we
were going to do it and I don't think the film
would have been at all different if
we had had the million versus the 25.
I don't think a frame of the film would have been
any different and the success that that film had
it taught me how to make movies for nothing
and what it launched ultimately gridiron gang
and a lot of seven other movies of the week that
collectively did very well that all came from a
25 000 let's do this from a million dollar
budget so for me I always tell a filmmaker
what do you have access to what are your means
if you're going to write the check yourself
what can you afford how can you do this really
break it down let's not think about putting all
the money in your pocket let's think about
building content are you going to be able to
own the library when it's all said and done it's
become a valuable asset to you 20 years from now
and I think it just in most of the the the talks
that we give with with producers and webinars it's
it's the main reason people are not making their
content is because they can't raise the money
that they've this self-imposed budget and I just
think sometimes if they they really really learn
the craft of of how to get things done and not
chins out on what your ultimate vision is I mean
it's not about cheapening out or chinsing out okay
sure you're not going to get george clooney on a
500 000 budget versus a 50 million budget but is
you trying to get that 50 million dollars gonna
be ten years from now you talking about getting
that movie made still or have you moved on to five
other movies you still haven't made and and for me
it's about getting excited about making a project
and doing everything you can to get it done and
okay this is what we have to do it we're getting
it done for this let's go and that that's probably
one reason that I that I have the career I have
where it's it's not about the budget and what it
has to be it's this is what we can do our next
project for let's create this content for this
budget and and every project you do is going to
build you to another level whether it's dollars or
actor level or distribution or whatever you have
to look at this this industry we we hear about
the success stories but for for most of us it's
truly a marathon it's not a sprint and you have to
look long-term it's like when you put money into
a cd or an ira it's long-term growth and you
have to look at this career like that because
having a script you're running around town with
trying to raise 10 15 20 million dollars on
and not getting it done does not get anything done
but if you're able to get similar content or even
that that passion project to yours done for the
money that you really can get or or raise and you
get it done it's just going to build and build
and build to get to where you ultimately want
to go and personally i'd rather have four
or five films under my belt in five years
than talking about making one that's just me
personally just that's my advice to filmmakers is
really think about what you can do something
for and where is this budget coming from
because if the content is good and the
cast is respectable enough to get eyeballs
you're you're going to have hopefully some
success with it you're going to move it
and just because the budget's high does
not guarantee success it doesn't guarantee
distribution there's a lot of very expensive
movies that are sitting in cans right now
that have been done for years with a-list
stars that have never seen the light of day
and then go make content that's what it's about
would you say you're asking for less money these
days when you approach an investor absolutely I
mean the the go-to for everybody I think that is
pitching an investor is well there's so much so
much opportunity for for distribution now well
there might be but what does it pay the home video
market is done that was really the biggest revenue
that we were seeing on our independent films when
when blockbuster and Hollywood video was out and
before the netflix world the money that us
indie folks saw was was pretty substantial on
the returns that's not happening anymore so you're
streaming you're seeing sometimes pennies pennies
for streams and aod and vods where before you were
seeing dollars so what we try to do is we we've
got it figured out how to make films on a dime and
make them at least the production value is good
so what we do is we present a product that is
marketable it looks good it fits with everything
else that's happening that we were able to produce
for a fraction of the cost of what everybody else
is making it for which when it sells the deals are
smaller but the investors are still happy because
the risk was low the rewards are what they are but
it all it all comes parallel what's happened is
the budgets for the films that we do at like 500
650 000 when home video was around that was gold
but because everything's streaming now for the
most part you may get a few tv deals that pay okay
but you don't want to count on those those are
those are like easter eggs are great when you find
them but you want to keep your investors happy
money out money in and the returns on those are
not only lower they also take forever to pay these
streaming deals when you work with a distributor
they usually have 90 days after the previous
quarter to pay well they're still dealing with
the same thing at their end from the streaming
platforms so the streaming platforms could take
90 to 120 days to report and pay them and then
they have another 90 days after the quarter
to pay you so you could be looking at eight
nine months before you see a dime on a stream
so these are things that you have to be very
upfront about with your investors you have
to let them know that this is this is the way
it is now the misnomer is that there's so many
big dollar deals for everybody you hear and read
about the big dollar deals that's that's what
keeps the wheels turning but the majority
is you're dealing with smaller deals and I
really encourage filmmakers to try to keep their
their budgets lower so they can get more content
made you can really learn how this industry is
working if you're not working at the studio system
what would you say is the sweet spot that an
independent filmmaker should spend on their movie
I think a sweet spot for an independent
filmmaker is it's different for everybody because
content different content drives more dollars
internationally comedy if it's circumstantial
comedy that's one thing but if it's it's written
comedy it doesn't always translate foreign
so you're limiting your foreign certain films
don't do well overseas so I don't think there's
a sweet spot for everybody I think there are
sweet spots that people can do and if you're going
to spend more money just put it in the cast it
really is it's if there's content there's content
that fits a niche or a genre
but then there's also star power
and if you're trying to get a-list actors
they're always going to cost you a lot of money
so some independent filmmakers do very well
they'll make three or four million dollar films
they'll put two million dollars into two actors
and then everything else is the rest of the film
there's nothing wrong with that if you're
doing the walk and talk dramas I unless you're
you're knocking it out of the park with star
power why do these films need to be made for
more than three hundred thousand dollars I just I
don't know why they would need to be if you're not
if you were not justifying it with the star power
again spend 10 million if you're getting george
clooney and meg ryan or whoever's hot today
it changes every other day that's justifiable
globally that's going to do a lot for your
revenue but if you're working with actors that are
really good at their craft that that are blue
collar actors that are going to get the job done
but they're not marquee you really got to think
about how you can keep the costs down because
again the less you spend the less you're going to
make especially when it comes to talent but again
you have to navigate what it is you're selling if
you're selling action what are the star power that
you need to pull the action film or is it going
to do good globally besides here in north america
horror does that translate worldwide does
psychological thrillers do well every film
genre has its goods and bads all over the globe
and you really need to research that before you
find your sweet spot and we find our sweet
spot just by trial and error I mean we haven't
we haven't hit home runs every time we make
a movie base hits and doubles are wonderful
but you really you really need to understand the
playing field before you find your sweet spot
and I think it's different for every every
genre and it's different for every filmmaker too
if a filmmaker is going to raise money then
we should just probably pick some ballpark
figure so maybe 500 000 okay how can a filmmaker
mitigate risk I think when when putting together
a half a million dollar budget the best way to
mitigate risk on that is to think about genre
think about star power as I as I try to tell a lot
of producers if you if you're only thinking about
what the public perception is of your work
and the stars that you are working with is
your end game you're not never going to be
happy be smart in your casting just because
somebody is not a-list studio powerhouse player
today doesn't mean they weren't 5-10 years ago
doesn't mean somebody isn't on three television
series that are syndicating around the globe two
or three times a day in 140 different countries
those actors are gold and they're not expensive so
when when we when we cast our films it's
about familiar faces it's about people with
good reputation people that we enjoy being
with 18 hours a day anyway right but I think
for mitigating risk it's about it's about getting
actors that people recognize and people can say oh
I remember this actor from that series or this
series or that show or that film and it's when
you're working in a half a million dollars
it's really not a lot of money it goes fast
and to be able to put maybe 35 40 of that above
the line I think is is smart and then you you got
your your crew and all below the line make sure
that's an efficient team that makes your product
look and sound good get good editors do whatever
you have to do to make the product look as good
as it can I mean you can make that that money go
a long way if how to do it but again it comes down
to content a five hundred thousand dollar drama
without the right cast is not the same thing as
a 300 000 action film with just one or two right
people in it I mean there they can be completely
different success so I always think it goes back
to really understanding globally what your product
how how products of that budget and that level and
similar cast do it's really important to look at
like films I mean us as filmmakers again it goes
back to thinking everything we do is so special
we're going to knock the world on its ass because
this is just the best script ever and it's going
to be the best movie ever I always say always go
in under promise over deliver and I think that's
the biggest problem with a lot of the pitch decks
that we look at that come through everybody's
got names and faces on these things they're never
going to acquire and they comp it to films they're
not even ever going to come close to comping
with they always pick the big grand slam films
and and what I try to teach producers is that
when you go in with all these promises and hype
you're going to start casting your film and you're
going to have two strikes against you when your
your investor says well who's in it and you didn't
get the names of the faces that were in your pitch
deck and I think that a lot of people go in such
high expectations and they get reality check sure
you're going to get the occasional like wow I
can't believe we got this person or that person
but when when you're pitching to investors I
always say let's just remember the investors are
smarter than we are we're going to them for money
because they are successful at doing things and
it's very similar to real estate if somebody came
to you and said I want you to put 500 grand into
this housing project and within 16 months you're
going to make 20 million dollars you probably
wouldn't invest especially it wasn't an accredited
builder developer or somebody that and see the
track record that okay their half million dollars
turns into 20 million within a year and a half
and a lot of filmmakers go in with that kind of
pomp and circumstance what I like to do when I
pitch investors is I use films that most people
haven't heard of is comps where I say hey this
film was made for 500 grand it made back 3 million
this film was made for 600 grand it made back
seven million because I'm not going to compare
it to blair witch I'm not going to compare it to
napoleon dynamite those are sh th that stuff's all
lightning in a bottle and and good on them there's
nothing no ding against them it's just that's
reality and investors sniff that bs a mile away
I think the most important thing when you're
pitching people for money is is you go and you
make the film as low as you can because the first
thing an investor always wants to know is how
much money are you getting paid we talked about
that in some of our earlier interviews I think
how much do you pay yourself or what shouldn't it
what should you be paid and the old saying is the
the producer is always the first one to buy lunch
and the last to get paid right I think investors
like to see you're not lining your pockets they
want to know you have certain skin in the game
and when you go to them and you say look your 500
000 investment if we place it here here and here
with this star power could generate two to five
million dollars over the next three to five years
all of a sudden they don't feel they're getting
a snow job and that's that's the reality of our
business and that's if you're doing well
so I think what's really important is it's
you ask about finding the sweet spot on budget I
think it's about I think you always have to put
your investor first because a lot of people just
want to get one movie made and they figure they're
going to move on to the next and where we've been
very successful is having a track record with
with investors we don't do one-off investors we
work with the same people over and over again
and that comes from trust it comes from delivering
it comes from putting a product on the screen that
they can be proud of when it's done and and having
success globally and it takes time it nothing
happens like that and and that's I think the
problem is is all these pitch decks that come in
are just lined with bs and fluff and hype and
I think if people just take a step back and
kind of do a reality check and what they're
presenting I think they'd be a lot more successful
in getting funds it's just about honesty and
integrity and you said also not just the images
and and in the pitch decks but also shooting
something like a scene that goes so much further
than I I look at some of these pocs that people
shoot and they just look they look so good I I've
never been impressed with the pitch deck and it's
just littered it's littered with [ __ ] I just got
sent a 60-page pitch deck that I I'm consulting
a producer on next week he sent it to me
I shot holes in 95 of it and they spent a lot of
money getting this pitch deck made it is useless
and it's really unfortunate because I see it all
the time and it's it's not that I have all the
answers I've raised a lot of money from private
equity that's what I do I know when they know
they're getting bs and I know what not to do
and these pitch decks are just constantly just
just filled with so much information
it's paperweight that they don't need
less I'm a big I'm a big proponent of less is
more in the room I talk about it in the book
the first time I ever raised private equity I
went into a very successful businessman's office
got took three months to get the meeting I
brought in a briefcase filled with scripts
budgets we didn't have the term pitch deck back
then but head shots and what we're going to do
and all the projections and the ask and takes from
the distributors and all the people that wanted to
sign on and I literally I literally broke out
this this kinkos box if you guys remember what
that is kinko's I think it's fedex printers now
I broke out a box and a guy said stop what are
you giving me I said oh I have a script I
have a budget he said look around my office
and cornered a corner of his grand office
there was stacks of paper knee to hip high
all over the place there's just paper and he
said these are all proposals from people that
want money from me he said you want to end up
in the pile give me your paperwork why don't we
just sit here and have a conversation you tell me
what it is you want to do how much money you need
how long is it going to take for me to start
seeing a return what are you going to do with it
and we were able to have a conversation bang
bang bang and that's that's how our our funding
comes it's not with pitch decks it's not with
reels it's not with anything other than just
eye contact and honesty and integrity most of our
outlines when we when we meet with investors is
three to five pages tops they're really small
and it's just it's just facts here you go
so then where where is the idea of these elaborate
pitch decks come from oh I think it's brand I
think somebody came up with the idea that they
make a lot of money getting them from filmmakers
to build a pitch deck I don't know and and I'm
sure they work I know there are platforms that do
seminars on pitch decks and I'm sure they work
for people I'm not saying they don't work for
everybody I just know that I see my share of them
because a lot of people send them in and say hey
will you give me your thoughts on this pitch
deck and they are just loaded with [ __ ] and
I really believe less is more it's two plus two's
gotta equal four in an investor's mind a lot of
people that you go to for money have been pitched
everything and they they pay business managers and
accountants a lot of money to protect them and
they're all told the same thing don't invest in
the music industry the film industry nightclubs
or restaurants right that's like the first thing
when you get money you're told what not to do
so you already go in with a strike against you
when you meet with an investor and they've seen it
all they've heard it all and they know that they
have the ability to make your dreams come true by
just saying the three-letter word yes and I think
speaking too much in the room is wrong I think
even a fool is considered wise when they're quiet
wait for questions to be asked stay on point don't
over analyze everything I've seen more deals get
killed in a room because a potential investor
will ask a question and there's a 30 minute
answer I know I'm long-winded that's my nature but
in the room it's a whole different ball game yes
no if they ask for something you tell them
how it's going to be and you shut your mouth
and people ruin their own deals time
and time again with too much information
and as I talk about in the book don't be afraid to
say I don't know one of the greatest most fruitful
relationships I ever had with a with an investor
came from saying I don't know he asked me a
question I didn't know the answer and I said sir I
don't know but i'll find out for you and what that
did is allowed me an excuse to contact them again
in a day or two with the answer to the question
they wanted to know and I called him back I got
him through their secretary he got on the phone he
said yeah what do you want and I said look really
enjoyed our time together a couple days ago you
asked me a question I didn't have the answer and
he said I did I said yeah I told him this was your
question this is the answer he said I got to tell
you something after you left my attorney and I we
enjoyed our meeting with you we made fun of you in
some respect but at your expense that happens we
make fun of everybody who comes in and tap dances
for money he said but we we were really moved by
the fact that you said you didn't know the answer
to something because it showed us that you're
willing to say you don't know you were willing
to be honest enough not to bs your way out of it
and you took the time to find out he said
well listen I appreciate the information
I'm going to let right now I'm just going to say
yes to your proposal let's move forward and do it
that that wound up being like a a financial
relationship that went on for for I don't know
how many films and how many years and that's that
was birthed out of just saying I don't know so
when it comes to trying to raise private equity
it's important to remember these people are
smarter than you and they've heard it all and and
I they they can usually smell right through the bs
cut to the chase with them
they know why you're there
but when they said they made fun of you did they
tell you what some of the things were like oh
eventually they did well you get nervous when
you're you're tap dancing for for your next
meal you sometimes you tremble sometimes you say
things wrong I think I spilled water on their
coffee table not anything but they gave me a glass
of water and I think I was reaching for something
and I spilled and it was I was nervous it's
like my first it was my first attempt at getting
capital I was scared it seems forgivable
but yeah okay yeah but it was funny to them
I guess so let's see the indie guy squirmed yeah
oh my god and what's funny is what happens i'll
tell you i'll tell you something we talk
about money I've had investors call back
when they don't always say yes and it's why
do you need so much money people are making
movies on a dime now it seems it doesn't seem like
you're blowing stuff up you're not hanging off the
empire state building why do you need so much
money investors are getting more and more savvy
about what things really cost they become very
wise to it there's just so much information at
their fingertips now the people that they surround
themselves with they they are paid to investigate
and know what things really cost the days of going
into people and asking for millions of dollars or
getting further and further I mean there are
those rare exceptions but I think you also have
to be really savvy on on an investor's ability
keep in mind what just because somebody's rich
doesn't mean they can just roll over and write you
millions of dollars in checks you don't know what
their overhead is that their exposure is what
other responsibilities they have what tax needs
they have or have to avoid so I think it's it's
really important to if somebody is is introducing
you to somebody that is a potential investor you
need to do your research if somebody is saying I
want to I want to introduce you to somebody they
could be a potential investor take the time to say
what do they do what is their family size what
are they they got houses all over the world are
they they live a modest lifestyle are they flashy
find out research them google's a wonderful thing
find out some of the things that have happened
in their life their successes and their failures
make sure they haven't had family tragedies that
is your project may remind them of and I'm a firm
believer whenever you go into the room to pitch
somebody whether it's an independent financier or
it's a studio always have two or three projects
under your belt or under your your arm because
you may say something and start down the road of
a project and they can say yeah no no no we're not
interested we don't want to make film like that
or we're not interested we developed something
like that it didn't work you wait two or three
months to get a meeting with somebody and they
tell you in the first two sentences of your pitch
this isn't going to work for them that meeting
is either over or you can say okay respectfully
understood put it away pull out another project
so if they're accountants let's suppose
these are not quote unquote film people
these usually are okay so so they're
people that have made money in other
industries and their accountants or business
managers to tell them stay away from the
following things which include making a film
why do you think they would even say yes
um well I think there are people that haven't been
told that or if they have they're still open to it
I will be I would say that most of the people that
I have been fortunate enough to do business with
have said to me early in a relationship don't
ever ask me to fund a film I would never do that
and you look at it you say well okay but
people who are doing films are doing very well
if they're if they're done properly and the model
is done and the budget's safe and the output
justifies the investment and there's also so
many incentives to investors that they're not
even aware of whether it's the write-offs that
they can get and again I always say talk to your
accountant every situation is different
everybody's tax situation is different
every state has different laws and there's
different things that need to be considered but
there have been bills put into place like
the jobs act that'll and bless an investor
for investing in a film there are also investors
that have companies that if you can justifiably
involve that company that they own in the
advertisement aspect that they can actually get
that film's investment written off as an
advertisement expense and it can do that
long-term depreciation I've even had investors
say to me don't don't pay us any money back right
now we're taking a hit on this for a while for
the company you got to slow the roll on some of
these returns I mean that does happen everybody's
situation is different but there's the reality of
when people make big money and a lot of things are
accessible on what people make or how successful
they are I always say cut those numbers in half
they're all fabricated or they're pre-tax dollars
and people have people at that level are pretty
responsible usually especially if they've been
around a long time and they come from older
money that they didn't just make it yesterday
by picking magic six numbers you really have to
go in and just because somebody's worth a hundred
million dollars it doesn't mean you ask for 10
or it doesn't mean you ask for one why don't
you start small and gain their trust have a base
hit or a double and then they can go back and say
what else do you want to do and so we'll have
this other project we'd like to do the budget's
a little higher than last time and if you've had
success you're not going to have an issue with it
I've learned some from some people that are very
close to me that have had a lot of success that
they're successful because of what they say yes
and no to smart people in development or in real
estate they'll make they'll make a move on a piece
of property and they look at it and say can I make
3x on this in 24 to 32 months and if the answer is
no they don't buy the property so as a filmmaker
you can't guarantee that so what is your pitch
going to be what is your angle going to be and
that's how a lot of savvy investors think and
then it goes back to the bs and the fluff on
a pitch deck trying to appeal to that mindset and
nine times out of nine you're not going to fulfill
those promises so you have to be very careful in
your presentation some of our investors said look
I know you don't want to hear this you
come off a 30 million dollar studio film
you you can do something with a hundred grand
show what you can do with a hundred grand
that makes sense we'll move on we'll get bigger
and bigger sometimes you gotta come back and
say look with that hundred grand you're not gonna
have the success you're gonna hope to see because
with that money you're offering we can't get
the star that's gonna move this over the hump
so can you come up to 150 give me another 50 grand
so I can get this actor or that actor and i'll
show you what I can do for the 100 plus the talent
side and then we can have a conversation and often
they'll say oh okay I understand how that works
now and they'll start working with you on that
you got to be open and fluid and those
doors should never be closed I've had
everybody who's ever invested in me has told
me no everybody I nobody has rolled over and
said absolutely let's do it it's it's
always come from people who have said no
right as the first absolutely even even the
gentleman who financed my first film wasn't
the first time I've come to him for money
yeah it took five years to get them to do it
so it did yeah it's always been those everybody
I've everybody I've been blessed enough to be
backed by has started with with seasons of
no's or just don't don't come to me for film
I don't want to do it what kind of money
are distributors paying for movies today
it depends I mean you could get you can get
a good distributor to come in and it's all
about territories how much term how long is the
contract going to be making deals with certain
platforms or certain distributors looks really
good on social media and cocktail parties but
some of those deals can go 25 30 years now and
they pay a couple hundred grand maybe maybe more
but what are they owning and for how long and
what does that limit your other sales potential
I'm a big fan of trying to sell films territory
by territory there are times where you get
opportunities to sell them in a block where
somebody will come along and say we want to own
10 11 territories and here's what we're willing to
pay sometimes it's good sometimes it's not I think
you have to look at both sides of it you have to
look at the long term or how long are they going
to have it sometimes these these awful financial
offers come with 30 years on the other side
where I'm 50. I don't I don't need to be 80 to get
the rights back so sometimes the lesser money per
territory if it's shorter term three to five years
could be more attractive every deal is different
you may get every territory spending between 10
and forty thousand dollars but there's ultimately
fifty plus territories to sell around the globe
they take time a lot of them don't pay up front
a lot of them don't pay until they
have it delivered and it's past qc so
just because you make a deal you
may not see the money for six months
people forget that so that's again why when you're
an independent filmmaker I think you have to look
at the the real picture it doesn't mean you're not
going to have something that just surprises the
world and you just make a huge deal that that does
happen but it doesn't happen to everybody so to be
a blue collar filmmaker and to be able to continue
to do what you do you have to to keep that in mind
I think you have to you realize that the average
deal is going to probably be five to seven years
that a territory is going to come in are they
going to pay 50 upon execution of the deal are
they going to pay 50 upon delivery that's that's
an attractive way to go where they're going to
put up 50 upon signing and then when you get
to your sales agent you're going to have a
quality qc version master that they'll be able
to deliver and all that went through so you're
not doing a territory for territory
once you have that qc that's passed
that show that's past muster everybody's
going gonna get that when they get it
but I no two deals are the same you can have one
film where all of a sudden the uk or germany is
paying 45 50 grand and then china is going to pay
10 or 15 and then you can have another film where
china's paying 35 40 and then the uk is
paying 10 or 15. I mean it's it's never
consistent again it goes back to genre big genre
also cast does it fit what they're looking to do
but again as I talk about in the book there's
there's 54 territories on the globe 172 buying
countries right so you have to realize that some
of those territories are going to pay crap they're
going to pay five seven ten grand but you do
have some that are going to pay very well and you
you have to break that down when again when you
budget a film always think with the end in mind
if I make this film and it's this genre and
this is the cast I'm realistically going to get
globally what is that actor or these few actors
do in a film of this nature or of this genre
and really break it down don't look at ask and
take sheets that every sales agent is going to
give you that tells you they're going to
ask for 150 grand in germany and accept
75 grand that's never going to happen that's those
are just numbers that they just provide these ask
and take sheets they're the same ones it doesn't
matter whose names on them they all look alike
don't go by that and sales agents will provide
that for you to get your business it's called
an ask take sheet and it's it's very
rare those numbers even come close
define a walk and talk a walk and talk drama I
don't even know if it's a real term I've i've
heard it used by sales agents and distributors
talking about films that you can look at something
like harry met sally could be considered like
a walk and talk romantic comedy it's it's not
an action film it's not set in outer space
or with green screens it's it's practical
I think like you've got males a great example of
a walk and talk it's it still has the romantic
comedy elements when we did mistrust with jane
seymour that was that was that's a walk and talk
drama okay that's the first time I've ever heard
the term and I started hearing it more and more
I think I think terms come and go but that's
that's my understanding of what it is I'm probably
wrong I'm sure your viewers will tell me how wrong
I am but that's that's what I understand it to be
and are those the hardest to sell they can be
tough depending on the cast so if if you're not
selling action you're not selling suspense
something that's getting the heart going
and it's it's a drama I you really need to push
the cast because you're asking people to you think
about you think about the independent films that
have done well and who's cast in them and what
they are and whenever whenever we're teeing up
to do a drama and we don't really do those much
anymore but when you tee out for him it's about
cast it's really just about cast that's important
we do an action film it's more about okay we've
got an action film coming let's think about some
of these actors who are going to do well globally
in different territories and why and action cells
suspense thrillers those things do well
everybody they translate into every language
and something else to keep in mind sorry i'll no
no go ahead they translate and they translate in
different languages but something also think about
is when when you do drama it's something I talk to
people a lot about especially now coming out of
where we've been for the last year and a half do
we do we really want to deal with too much drama
anymore I mean I don't know and and the question
is is does the world want what we consider
drama do they want our drama do they want our
problems drama comes with a lot of emotion it
comes with a lot of feelings it comes with a lot
of baggage it doesn't it doesn't mean it's bad
it's it's what makes some of the great dramas
but I always I always try to to to remind people
think about what we're coming out of people have
been living in their their homes or their their
dwellings for a year and change and they haven't
been able to socialize much they haven't gone
on vacation take them places they want to go
let them experience exciting things that never
gets old people want to see beautiful things
and get excited and I think you can incorporate
that in drama but don't forget always think
about where the world is right now and what
if you were totally detached from this film
completely detach yourself from it think about
the year you've just had do you want to sit
and watch somebody else go through some drama
right now totally for the drama genre I love it
but I just think you have to be sensitive to the
global climate when you're making certain product
but the queen's gambit worked that was going to
work that was just awesome would you say that
was some action or no not not really but it had
sensuality it had it had some eroticism to it it
had mystique it had edgier seat moments because
of some of the things that she went through with
her addictions and dealing with her family
drama and and her background I mean I think
if I remember correctly I saw it not a long time
ago now but I think she was a was she adopted or
something she was in an orphanage orphanage yeah
yeah I mean there's there's a lot of baggage there
but they were able to educate an audience and
what I thought the coolest thing was and nobody
was surprised is when they talked about the
number of chess chess games that sold after
the success of that film and they couldn't keep
chess in stock this became the hottest thing in
the world everybody's buying chess and I always
so obviously they did something besides being
just such a brilliant execution of such a great
show is it it got people excited about a new hobby
and and that's a cool thing too and we could root
for the underdog even though she was kind of three
steps ahead of most of the people oh she was but
she was but in watching the chess games and and
the looks on the little the little tells and the
micro expressions and things and and wondering was
this going to be the one that was going to take
her down yeah that's right and all of the you see
popping circumstance that was around certain
the the notorious players and then sure this
she's going to come in so it was great I liked
I liked the janitor that taught her how to play
benny he needs a spin-off he sure does yeah yeah
yeah I wasn't sure where we were going with him
at first I wasn't either I was like ah it's a
little creepy and then I realized oh okay okay
he's a good guy I know exactly but yeah it had
that intrigue but no I think there's nothing
wrong with drama but I think during the drama you
have to have those those moments to breathe and
and experience new things as a filmmaker we've
talked about it before filmmaker's job is to
bring an audience to some place they've never
been never knew existed who's always afraid to
have gone to or always wanted to go and I think
in drama you can still do that even with some of
the experiences or adventure that maybe a romance
let's say it's a a romantic it's not a comedy but
it's a romantic drama there's drama and maybe
somebody's a widow or somebody is cheating on a
spouse and they're going through this journey of
a new relationship and that's that's when things
almond king did very well if you watched
like nine and a half weeks what made that
in its time was was what that relationship did
between the incredible sex scenes the thrill and
the exuberation of that relationship and where it
took its viewers and it's time and I think that's
important to do sure and there was romance in the
queen's gambit there was that's right that's right
but there was also excitement and the way and
then i'll just close it there but just that a
lot of the shots were I'm not sure what the exact
terminology is but there are like these upshots of
of them following her upstairs and getting like
this wide view of her sort of walking into a room
and but but also in your right and what was
really cool about it is they took us places
we've never been and her journey when she became
a professional chess player the places around the
world she went and some of these incredible
rooms and these halls and these hotels and
we got to experience that especially
during covid when we were all stuck at home
is when most of us saw that and even shit's
creek you talk about a show that exploded
during the pandemic I mean everybody was talking
about that show early on in the pandemic and and
here was just this great concept of this this very
wealthy family that everything stripped from them
that had to go to this small town but what what
fun and that's circumstantial comedy that I think
translates a lot better than slapstick comedy
because people can get that from all walks of life
every language that'll translate so I think you
just have to be smart in picking your content
just you have to again we talk about how us
artists are so myopic and selfish we just
have to take a step back and say okay if you were
detached from this realistically how do you think
this would be accepted take your passion take your
investment of your time or your your your talent
away from this for just five minutes really think
about how this would do on a global scale and why
how much money can filmmakers expect to make from
streaming services today don't expect anything I
think every deal is different every situation is
different there are there are some really cool
streaming services or platforms that are
popping up all the time that tubi's a new one
obviously you've got your netflix your amazon
your hulu I think I think netflix if you make a
deal with them they acquire the project I think
I think people will be surprised for what they
actually acquire independent films for and people
need to realize they pay that over I think two
years it's not just one big check and that's fine
that's that's what they do there are some some aod
platforms that are that are doing surprisingly
well I never say what anybody should expect
I work with sales agents and distributors all
the time that are working with films that have
been dead catalogued collect dust in a closet
haven't seen a light a day in 15 20 years they're
throwing them on some of these aod platforms
and they're bringing in 5 to 20 grand a month
just on like dead titles it and then you
have stuff that costs a lot more that are
recent and slick and they're not making a dime
there's I don't think there's there's really a
guarantee for anything I I think that there are
some really good streaming platforms out there
there's some obviously the the more the merrier
if you can get different territories different
platforms they have some platforms now that'll
get your your work out on you can make deals
with some distributors they'll get your get
your work out on 32 different platforms every
major cable outlet including xbox and playstation
I mean those are some really attractive things but
how well do they pay I don't want to give you
a number and say this is what you can expect
because it what we always have to remember about
this business is to hope for the best prepare
for the worst and expect the unexpected and it
goes back to learning something new every day
there are some streaming platforms that I've heard
or just oh my god you got to get with them and
you see what the deal is and you just say that's
the last thing I want to do and then there are
some platforms that you've never heard of that
you just say I wouldn't be caught dead being
affiliated with this and then they say well sit
down here's what our mg is we're going to give you
a minimum guarantee for one year and then after
the second year you have first right of refusal
if you're happy with that we're going to pay you
40 afterward you sit there and you go so wait
you're going to give an mg on a streaming deal for
that much money huh okay and these things I mean I
get hit with these things every other day where
there's the misconception of some of the bigger
ones and then there's this I've never heard of
you before but you're willing to guarantee it
I wish I had the answer for you but I think
it's one of those things that every film
every film with a cast from every filmmaker is
going to be treated differently in that I just do
I just do I don't think there
is a tried and true number yet
there's too many new platforms popping up they're
everywhere from our previous interview Shane we
had one video that had a lot of comments that
we were hoping to run by you and maybe get some
clarification on the big reason why many people
will never have a career in the film industry
and so here's one comment sounds great in theory
but we literally can't afford to spend our time
not getting paid these days honestly lol I could
read another if you'd like okay okay you can
hustle be the quote johnny on the spot and still
fall through the cracks starting out I worked on a
ton of projects for free as much as I could living
at home and later when I saved up and moved to la
but eventually those resources run out and
you have to pay rent there's a definite class
element to being able to go out and spend two
years working for free nobody should work for
free here's another one quick question if you
work on a movie 12 plus hours a day for a month
and you do that for a year or so for free dot
dot dot how exactly do you pay rent question mark
okay here's another one I've been working my
tail on I'm gonna probably tail off that's
just thinking about working the tail off working
their tail yeah wax on wax off sorry okay I've
been working my tail off on crappy jobs outside
the movie industry and I cannot accept unpaid
jobs inside the industry because I have to eat and
live and that costs money I am a little confused
about this attitude of stanley thanks that you are
supporting such a bad role model I'm a bad role
model okay god I feel bad that so much of this was
misconstrued and I don't blame the the the viewers
and and i'd first like to apologize if anything
was misunderstood I am not telling you to sell
your soul work for free live on the streets and
not pay rent let me clarify a few things with that
because I encourage you to get out there and
work and hustle and do what you have to do to
get on a set a lot of the sets that you're
going to get on cannot afford you anyway
and they or they are already filled and what my
point was it doesn't mean you go work 75 hours a
week for free six days a week on a film it means
you make yourself available to a producer or a
filmmaker and say look I have a job I need to get
time on a set can I put in two days a week I'm off
saturday and tuesdays I'm off the weekend I'm off
at night and get yourself involved and in the loop
of people that are doing what you ultimately
want to do I'm not saying that you've got to go
live in your car to go work for free I personally
worked for free a lot but I also had other
jobs just because I had a father in the industry
trust me it didn't help me in a way that a lot of
people think it might have when I when I decided
that I wanted to make a living in film the only
thing my father gave me was his rolodex he
said great there you go some of the people
in there make some calls I worked for hundreds
of different people before he hired me full-time
I wasn't until my mid-20s until I was working with
my dad full-time we had a lot of success early on
with his documentaries and shows that he did we
did one every two years I moved out when I was 18.
I didn't have my rent covered I was out hustling I
held odd jobs I sold cars I worked at restaurants
I waited tables I bus tables I detailed cars I
mowed lawns I painted houses I did construction
I still found a way to get on a set every week
and put in my time to make new contacts so what
I'm trying to encourage you guys to understand
is it's not going to come to you you have to make
sacrifices I am not asking you to [ __ ] yourself
out and work for free for everybody all the time
to start to get a track record as a reliable
resource on a set it's like interning we have
a lot of interns that come and go on our shows
from films from film school that work on our
productions we we get them when we can they
get credit some of our greatest regular crew
members that we pay are from interns from college
that came in and worked for two or three days
a week if we were lucky during a production from
four years ago it's just to encourage everybody
to understand it's not coming to you if it's not
coming to you how are you going to get something
if you want to get to an island it ain't
coming to you you either swim or take a boat
if you don't have money for a boat you don't have
the resources for a boat get in the water start
swimming that's all I'm trying to say it's to
encourage you guys to understand that's what I had
to do I brought up a friend of mine whose father
had two oscars his mother had I think five or
seven emmys when he pulled his head out of his ass
and decided he wanted to work in the film industry
he told his parents his plan assuming they would
get him work they said great dad picked up the
phone and I think he called deluxe which
was an old film color house back in the day
my friend was sweeping floors there for two
years before they let him sit behind an edit bay
that was the job he got the first year he was
there he was there two or three hours a day
and he wasn't paid that's just how it was back in
our day if I offend people of today's generation
because we actually worked for free and earned our
stripes by busting ass and bringing our own lunch
sorry you were offended but that's how we did it
we still have people that want to intern that show
up we still have great people that come in and
say look i'd like to give you a day on the set I
want to show you what I'm about because we're not
looking for the help we have the people that are
on the team so it's about people coming to us and
saying I want to show you what I can do for you
of course we're going to feed you we'll water
you come on out for a few hours show us what
you got so when we make our next film we know to
call you and there's a lot of filmmakers that are
willing to do that I used to call everybody I
knew in that rolodex and I called them and we
didn't have text and email it was phone calls and
it was hey phil hearn it's Shane stanley lee's son
yeah that one listen I need to get on a set do you
need somebody to be a pa in ac a second what can I
do to get on a set phil would call back sometimes
and say yeah if you want to come work on saturday
we're doing a show with richard krenna come on out
bring your own lunch i'll i'll get you on the set
giant getting paid and i'd show up I did that with
steve elkins phil hearn did that with ken shafer I
did that with with tom coster I did that with with
chad shoe cat I think got me on a couple of shows
it's just what we did and I hope and I understand
times have changed and all that but my my heart
and my spirit of telling you what I did last time
that ruffled some feathers was not sell your soul
and work for free for 70 hours a week do your meet
your responsibilities with your paying job but
we all don't work 70 hours a week for a paying job
so you find the time to get on a set even if it's
three hours a day and show people what you got
and be around people that are doing what you love
so they know that they can call and rely on you
that was the sole purpose of that why do you think
younger generations have reacted stronger than
maybe previous ones it's because a lot of interns
have been taken advantage of yeah I think so I
mean when you work with interns you can't you
can't replace interns you can't replace employees
with interns and I think ever since the big black
swan lawsuit that changed the dynamics we work
very closely with a lot of amazing schools the
laccla vc we're working with college of the desert
this year out in palm springs and pierce college
and the rules are simple is is give the kids the
opportunity let them shadow and and our our guys
on our crew are so amazing with them because
they they've been fortunate in their upbringing
and they understand what hard work is they don't
let the kids sit around they're like hey grab an
end of that come on let me show you how to
clean a lens we had interns literally doing
second ac duties for for a film when we had a
second ad I'm sorry second ac and and to watch
these kids learn how to pick up these 60 or 70
000 lenses and clean them and prep them and put
them on the cameras they're not learning that
in the classroom and I guarantee you they're
not learning that during a pandemic so we're
really big about interns coming out and learning
various jobs on the set we try to move them to
sound to camera to a.d upm they come shadow me
for a day they can learn everything what not to
do go into hair and makeup learn how that is go
learn wardrobe and how we tag everything for the
days and the scenes and how sometimes wardrobe is
used for half of the day it's put away we use it
for an hour something else and then we go back to
that and just the way the schedule is how we shoot
they don't learn these things in a classroom and
they're paying for an education that that they
get in a class and so when they're able to come
on a set with filmmakers that are willing to open
their doors and their hearts to say come learn
and that's that's what that's that's the
spirit of what I what I try to to encourage
Shane we're hoping to get your take on what
might be the problem with Hollywood movies today
I don't know if there's a w what is the problem
I think there's a lot of disgruntled unemployed
people bitching about what's being made because
they're not working I mean and that's that's
part of why I did what I did I got tired of
not working so went out and created content
I'm not knocking anybody who's not working I think
the big complaint from everybody is well it's all
sql prequel and remake and it's all spandex men
in capes and spandex and action hero movies and
if that's what they're considering the problem but
there's still plenty of content I learned from a
studio head about nine years ago when when these
superhero movies were really becoming a thing
and and they told me you ain't seen nothing yet
it's going to get unbelievable with with different
studios buying acquiring different branches of
different comic book companies whether it's dc or
marvel or different one-offs in in like remaking
movies that we've all heard of and I asked why
why do you do it he said well there's
a big audience for it and I get that
but they said the the branding's already there
when a studio makes a movie people forget that
there's a tremendous amount of pna that goes into
it princeton advertising and pushing this thing
and when you have a project I mean you can take
something like jungle cruise I mean you've got two
of the biggest stars in the world in it everybody
knows what it is disney's jungle cruise I mean 140
000 people go to disneyland every day when there's
no pandemic so everybody should know that that's
built in branding it's it's about for studios
it's it's you talk about mitigating the risk
you talk about lessening the chances of putting
all this money into television commercials and
billboards that are going to get covered by
another film next week and pushed aside and
people people already have a knowledge of what
it is because we've seen it as fantasy island
adam's new tv show that's been remade and is now
on fox we all know what fantasy island is that's
built-in branding they did it with dynasty they
did it with dallas they reboot everything now it
I don't think it's as much about there aren't any
new ideas I think it goes back to fear I honestly
think it goes back to fear with decision makers
wanting to make shows that were proven successful
at one time or had built-in branding that people
are going to want to watch for curiosity factor
they're going to want to watch because they loved
it at one time i'll tell you a show that would
blow it out right now that would do really well
they would just remake heart to heart can you
imagine that show today that's a modern day mr
mrs smith yeah that show would be a great remake
I it's just one of those things though I mean I
think the the remakes have become a bit much for
me art's nothing but opinion there is a hungry
audience out there for content I don't want to
say anything's wrong with Hollywood but I think
a lot of of disgruntled people in town that have
fresh ideas that they believe their scripts are
really different and good and they probably are
are upset when they see airspace and
screens filled with remakes that were done
20 30 years ago that's where the frustration
comes from and again I'm not knocking people that
are not working I mean again I got tired of
watching sequels prequels and remakes get made
and finally just said screw it I'm just
going to find a way to make my own stuff
because nobody else wants to maybe my stuff is
that bad but that's that's why I try to push
people to really find ways to partner with people
that can get their stuff done god forbid somebody
loves your little indie project and says you
should be directing the next superman I mean it
could happen and I I'm disappointed in Hollywood I
think there's a safety factor a lazy factor that's
come in I'm not gonna lie I don't disagree with
what you're saying and what people are saying
but the opportunity to to to get a studio or
a platform such as a netflix to commit if you
have an original series idea it's gonna cost
them between 50 and 150 million dollars for 10
hours of content that's a big risk on something
that hasn't been proven when everybody's afraid
to make a chance and when you're putting up
200 million dollars to put it on 4 000 screens
you're gonna tend to go for the tried and true
and I think that's really what they've done
and it's really hurt the new writer it's really
hurt the person that has honed their craft and has
written some great specs that are just not getting
looked at because there isn't a home for it
so my my advice is don't be angry it hurts
me when I see writers who are not working
blasting the things that are getting made it
seems the writers do that more than anything and
and I understand the frustration I'm
not saying you're wrong to feel that way
but I don't think you're doing anything good
for yourself by by blasting what's getting made
go make something better or just go make something
and show the world what you can do don't don't
talk about it be about it that's that's the advice
I give to people that that have aspirations again
I keep repeating myself it's not coming to you you
have to go on out and get it and whether that's
go work on a set a day or two a week for free or
it's going out and getting a dslr and a couple of
people from a local acting class and playing out
scenes and really doing a poc a proof of concept
on your vision of what your script can be that's
how that's how it's going to get done for you
that's that's my advice and that's my feeling
on it I think Hollywood has gotten quite lazy
I think they've gotten complacent I think they
are content with the numbers that they get with
their remakes of the same old same old I'm not
I'm not endorsing it at all that's why I go out
in the dirt and do what I do I don't personally
like that stuff at all I understand the anger and
the frustration but being angry about it and and
trying to get attention online or trying to pull
down other people that are doing stuff that you're
not doing doesn't it doesn't help anybody just
go show them what you can do sure I would enjoy
seeing a remake of alice or taxi oh taxi I don't
know striking a car that's one of my favorites I
don't even mean would people would be uber you'd
just call it uber that's true or lyft or yeah
just call it lyft or uber alice would be great
one of my favorite shows growing up with linda
lavin and victory back and yeah yeah that was a
great show for those of you who don't know what it
is look at some great television all in the family
could never be made again we know that but there
were some great shows that they haven't remade
but they they do they do find a way to keep
remaking and rebranding stuff and that's all about
built-in branding well two broke girls was similar
to alice in some ways but I realized it was much
raunchier and right right push some boundaries
it did yeah I don't think it get made today
oh you don't think so I don't know I didn't watch
the show but I've i've heard that that in some
of the discussions that I've had with some of
the writers that we do on some of the platforms
that we interact with aspiring screenwriters
and they want to pitch and they talk about
different things and somebody was talking about
two broke girls I've never seen an episode of it
and somebody had said do you think that that
would get made today and a lot of people said
no they pushed some boundaries so I just that's
one that's kind of like we obviously know blazing
saddles is the go-to that would never get made
today and you think about the content in that film
but forgive me two girl girls was like less
than 10 years ago right I think it was yeah so
so we've we've changed that much where we can't in
that short of time we it would be too much to push
I don't again I haven't seen it I just found
it interesting that it's funny whether it's an
industry conversation or it's just people the joke
is always like well blazing saddles would never
get made today that's like the go-to for film
and and it was just kind of weird that everybody
was kind of on this two broke girls bandwagon I
could be wrong I've been wrong 100 times today
but I just found that odd that people thought
so I thought it was a very successful sitcom
that looked endearing and fun and I'm afraid I'm a
fan of whitney I just never got into the show but
it just seemed to strike a chord with a few
people on these on these different webinars
we were doing and they all seemed kind of like
yeah do you think that would get made today
did they push them maybe it was racial or sexual
boundaries since me too since some of the other
things we've been through as a society did they
push those envelopes you would know you've seen it
I haven't seen that many episodes but I
know from the few that I did yes there was
definitely content on there I think that's
probably what's not which probably made the
show which probably made the show good
we have we have we went through a time
I'm probably gonna really ruffle some feathers
with this one so let's let's do it we went through
a time as a society we got so desensitized when
natural-born killers came out the big fear was
oh my god have we gotten to that point in society
where things are said and done and we don't even
blink at it anymore we don't care we're okay with
that and then now we've gotten to a point where
we really really are trying not to offend certain
people or push boundaries anymore and I think it's
really interesting how 50 when did when did
natural born killers come out 25 years ago
how that really turned it into how desensitized
we've become to now how sensitive we are
think about that I mean it's been a radical
shift especially in the last four years
well it seems like with cinema and television
but then everyone's okay pulling out cameras
if an incident happens in real life so
it's like it's okay for us to do that
and share some horrific things that way and
that's acceptable well it's real life that's
what's happening okay so then we don't want to see
it in the cinema even though this is what's being
apparently known okay but I always thought or
imitated life so okay I'm not disagreeing with you
I just but I see the difference yeah I knew the
gentleman who put the rodney king beating on the
air that was a much longer tape than we saw as a
public I think he acquired the tape for 300 from
the gentleman who got the camcorder and was
filming outside his balcony and it was very
disturbing there was nothing good about it
I'm not making light of what we didn't see
but there was a lot that wasn't shared with the
public and that changed everything so it really
when that rodney king incident hit the airwaves
as a society we we woke up to a whole different
animal in our in our the underbelly of what was
going on and I it's obviously what we went through
with george floyd in the last year and that being
caught on camera and and it's just it's you know
you're right I mean the things that are shown
that people are catching on live camera just
there's no we didn't think twice about it it's
shocking sometimes sure I don't know if again
we become desensitized to a lot of things we
see but do we want it in the art that we go pay
to see and is us as storytellers I think there
are some filmmakers and I and I mean this with
the purest of heart please understand where this
is coming from I think there are some storytellers
that have a a right and should be given the past
to show and exploit certain things in their art
because I think there's so much that we see on
a on a camera that's caught in 30 seconds where
so often when when the right artist tells that
story they get into the build up they they get
into the aftermath we we're so used to seeing news
like that we'll look at somebody have a fit and a
walmart because they're not wearing a mask we'll
see somebody get choked out by a police officer
and it just comes at us at the speed of light
and when somebody can take an hour and a half
two hours and really break down the psyche and the
build up and what happened and then the aftermath
we don't have when we see something shocking
on the news which is usually what news is now
50 somebody's camera it feels like there's never a
follow-up it's very rare they may say oh there was
there was sadly there was somebody killed
in a street race they found the guy
but we don't get the aftermath that's a good point
and that's that's what I don't like about the news
is obviously we did with george floyd and some of
the other situations that are similar that we've
been dealing with as a society because it's it's
warranted that and it's it's it's attracted that
much attention and rightfully so but we watch
stuff all the time on on social media that we
just went through it and we watch something crazy
it goes on for 20 seconds we whip through it see
something else we never know the outcome of that
we don't know what caused it and I think there are
some artists that are sensitive enough they have a
sensitivity in the ability to really tell a story
from beginning to end in aftermath beginning
middle end and dominate of what happened and
I think too many of us storytellers just feel
what we're storytellers we can do it and I think
I think there's a very very select few who have
the right to do it would you say that filmmakers
today are more about forcing a message than
telling a good story that's a great question um
i think I think there's there's quite a few that
do that I think telling a good story is important
whether it's it's a fun romp in the desert or it's
a story about a collapse of the housing industry
like the big short I mean wow was that a message
or was that a story yeah I think it was both
I really do will we learn from it time will
tell I think set your watch to that but
I think as storytellers we have a responsibility
as writers we have a responsibility a lot of
people I think I think well if you look at the
faith based genre it's all about the message they
don't care about story as much as they do it's
the message it's the message it's the message and
that's cool that's that's their thing sometimes
the story is good I'm not saying they're not
always but there's there's its message is the
the integrity and the point behind those I don't
I don't know what what different
artists intent is I think some
people go in with the intent to tell a
good story and it becomes message heavy
and I think the other way around too sometimes
people go on wanting to give a message and it
ends up being a good story or it doesn't
I think I think everybody as a storyteller
has an intention whether they're willing to
show their hand or really I think the good
storytellers are able to do both without people
realizing what's happening I mean I think when
you can seduce an audience and kind of woo
them along and really get them in your story
regardless of what story you're telling whether
it's chariots of fire I mean you talk about that
that was a faith-based movie people don't realize
that that eric little not not competing on the
lord's day and the background of his religious
background there was a lot of religious undertones
in that but it was a hell of a story and it was
such a brilliant film and was it message driven
or was it story driven I think it probably
was a good hand of both in my opinion anyway
looking on golden pond henry fonda and jane fonda
I mean there was a story there but there was such
a message about family and communication and and
how we drift apart with age and circumstances but
I think there's a way to do both but your
question was do I think one one this is
people become more focused on one or the other I
think as we go through what we have in our times
I think I think a lot of people run to a message
as storytellers I think that's a big thing I see
a lot of short films and theses films that are
message driven and they're not thinking about the
story as much but that's that's coming from a lot
of film school students and newbies that they they
want to jump on a cause and and sometimes just
saying there's anything wrong with that I think I
think sometimes when you when you're dealing with
sensitive issues or you're dealing with subject
matters that we're still really feeling the
aftermath or the aftershock from that's a that's
a good way to get some attention as a storyteller
to to let people see what it is that you're trying
to do as an artist and sometimes you have to
you have to to pick the scab a little bit you
mentioned that taxi was one of your favorite shows
growing up was there a message with the tv show
was louis de palma was he did he have something
that he was trying to tell us and we didn't see it
I think he was just a I think I always
thought danny devito was the youngest
of probably five children and he probably like
arthur spooner and the king of queens never really
was heard growing up and he was a bully and the
funny thing was is he was five foot nothing 100
and nothing and ran the roost it was his show I
mean it was his that was his garage and there was
there was messages but occasionally he would have
a life lesson but before they faded to black you'd
always slide back to old louie right that's true
but but the things that judd hirsch's character
would would go through with tony danza or elaine
or bobby wheeler's character I forget his name
the actor that passed and my favorite was jim jim
mcnitowski christopher lloyd's character I mean
that was my favorite character I watched the show
for him as a kid I thought he was hilarious and
latke vodka was great that's great yeah yeah
and latke's wife yeah yeah I mean was there
a message I think you talk about people coming
from all different backgrounds and all different
walks of life and being able to work together and
encouraging alex was always kind of that wise owl
of the group they went to him for advice
or sometimes he got himself in a pickle
and elaine would help him out so I think
it's neat when shows that we and deer
touch on us without hitting us over the head
and I think taxi was a brilliant example of of
giving us little life lessons without ever feeling
like we were being preached at I like shows like
that don't hit me over the head let me enjoy the
people the circumstances and go along for the ride
and oh you happen to give me a little life lesson
here all right it was it was extra worth the time
whereas with fantasy island there was always
a message usually there was wasn't there once
when when mr rorke was was speaking to
tattoo at the end there there was some
kind of a message that that show was on past
my bedtime I never got through the third act
i don't know if they'll have the same message in
the remake but looks like they've really rebranded
it I like the fact that they have a woman now
as the mr roar character I think it appears that
way I haven't seen it yet but looking at some of
the previews of it I think they have a woman now
leading the charge which I think is great but yeah
there were messages I know there was about people
finding love or I think wasn't it again forgive
me I think it was also a lot of people fantasies
chasing something that they're never going to get
and being able to accept and love and appreciate
what they truly had as they think what kind of
was the underlying tone of the show wasn't it
as an audience member or fan do you feel that
movies today are lecturing you more than they
previously did not the stuff that I watch I don't
I don't allow myself to get into that I I'm very
time is precious our time on this earth is limited
something doesn't doesn't get me early I just I
have an off button like the rest of the world I
just I just don't go down roads that I just feel
if something's going in a direction that I don't
personally agree with or it just doesn't hold me
I don't wait it out i'd rather go on and
do something else so I can't answer that
I just I like shows that allow me to do the
things that I want to do when I tell a story
let people go where they haven't gone take
them someplace they didn't know existed I let
them just forget about their circumstances and
enjoy something for 90 minutes or however long
it is that they're watching but I always love
it when there's something there's always that
saying when we work on something we always we
always try to leave the audience with something
more than an empty box of popcorn at the end
of a show I think it's I think I think it's
a filmmaker's responsibility I mean no matter how
ragtag or crazy a show is I think I think there's
always I think show always needs heart you got to
have characters you care about and can relate to
so I think it's important that as storytellers we
allow our audiences to relate to characters or at
least want to learn more about a character and if
we have some self-discovery during the ride super
that's great I don't look for films like that
or projects like that when I watch something
but I like nice surprises as I said earlier I
think sometimes when you walk away from something
wow I gave me a different point of view or I
never thought of that or really interesting to
see a different side from of society that maybe
I don't come in contact with all the time and to
see their upbringing their point of view or one
of the shows that I'm absolutely in love with
is blanking on the name right now it's snowfall
john singleton created that show and basically
about the beginning of crack cocaine in the
inner cities and how that started I think that
is just such a brilliant show and I having come up
working with incarcerated youth during that time
we were really big in working with a lot of the
juvenile inmates and in the prison system during
those 80s and 90s and I was very involved with
a lot of the kids lives that were going through
slinging dope and making crack and selling it
and living in gangs and protecting their turf
and here I am 25 30 years later as
50 year old guy watching this show
it's like one of my favorite shows
on tv and that's something that I saw
close up that wasn't living the life but I was
close to it and integrated with people that were
I just think you talk about a show that you I
think you learned so much about the mindset of
it's a lot of people that it's easy to look down
on people that live a certain way and do a certain
thing to make money but you also have to look at
the circumstances and what their surroundings are
and either you're selling or you're living on the
streets broke or you're selling you're gonna die
because there's a lot of people that got pulled
into it that you had to choose an allegiance
so a lot of the people that got involved in
that they didn't really have a choice and
a lot of people it's it's good to remind people
where things come from I mean I think there's
some some interesting roads they go down with
the cia funding some of that to kind of do their
own thing and that's that's all if you're into
that that's cool I mean I don't take one side or
another on that but I love the show because I care
about the characters we we meet franklin and he's
this young kid who lives in the hood who
gets brought into this underworld and
he becomes a kingpin of moving narcotics into
the not only the inner city but our our world
and stories like that fascinate me and I think a
lot of people get that from shows like narcos and
other shows I haven't seen that one but I
sometimes there's message there's interesting
interesting things that come from those about
relationships and loyalty and sometimes I can
get inspired by a show like that that has nothing
to do with what I'm dealing with on a day-to-day
basis but it reminds me of the importance of
loyalty when I think of our film crew or I
think about the people that we work with or our
friends or family so it's nice when those little
these little things happen when you
watch a show that you don't expect from.